je veux c'est parce qu'il a joué dans
les ouvertures
ouais voilà c'est ça c'est ce que je
vais savoir est ce que tu veux vraiment
savoir est-ce que tu le sais toi même
déjà à regarder
regardez dans le chatt donner un côté
attend je n'ai pas vu encore on ne voit
pas on voit pas encore un écran vacciner
on le voit par an on le voit nantes what
what i'm on partage donc tu pour être
aujourd'hui tu pourras voir mon partage
par contre avec avec les caméras c'est
le point c'est le point positif
ouais donc là il s'est levé de sa chaise
je veux voir s'il est en forme je sais
qu'il a fait des petites études ce matin
les a reçus au réveil
voilà là je pense qu'il a fait une bonne
sieste cet après midi pour être en
superforme pour ce match moi j'ai un
petit peu parlé tout à l'heure on a
parlé siesta on a parlé on a parlé quand
existe un on parle beaucoup de sister ah
ben je crois que c'est un au sujet phare
bah ouais mais bon ok on peut pas tenir
si on fait passer cela kevin je sais mes
mails même entendre un toit et moi on
parle souvent de siesta avec maxime on
parle souvent de systar et je crois que
c'est un autre sujet franchement on
parle de six tomes on parle aussi à 2h
ou 3h du matin ou quoi alors oui mais
est aussi à 8 heures du matin elle aussi
enfin bon donc la siesta devient
obligatoire un certain moment où mais il
a l'air en superforme maxime petit là oh
la la il y là il a l'art et la paix avec
lui en plus oui là les petits mcgill est
pas encore là calmes mais il ravitaille
au pap
abba label ab ap et bienvenue sur sur
les six mois
c'est un bon signe pour ce match ouais
bah écoute il était à on voit sa double
caméra
oui c'est l'enfer selon faire ce truc
toi tu toi tu vas voir les deux vrais le
public n'en verra qu'une mais toi tu
verras les deux oui donc tu vas tu as
quand même tu as quand même des
avantages ce soir pas de pas de pas de
quai des prix pas de kevin full time et
mais en contrepartie
tu as dû maxime ouais bah j'espère que
je te verrai un petit peu mieux comme
c'est un peu compliqué là pour moi
quoique je peux non mais je te vois la
base je me vois aussi complexe par
contre je vois pas je vois pas magnus en
fait pour le moment non bas et côtiers
dans abasse ba et ben on va peut-être
lancer les pendules
alors je ne sais pas si c'est moi avec
avec leurs trucs de zoom qui est un peu
mal foutu et tous entre est peut-être un
magnus en fait je suis censé l'avoir
mais je veux dire en fait comme comme
comme le che comme ce truc de zoom et
tout le temps mal foutu tu t'attendes
toujours un bug d'un autre monde donc je
me dis est ce que c'est pour ça que je
les ai pas et qu'on réussira jamais à
voir magnus ce qui m'inquiète un petit
peu ou alors alors attends ça vous fait
voir déjà si on est ce qu est ce que
tout le monde voit venir
déjà on est pas mal mais je pense juste
qu'il n'est pas encore arrivé en fait tu
penses je pense pareil que toi
oui bah réponse les pendules on se les
pendules tout de suite mais alors à
temps ci n'est pas arrivé enfin je sais
pas si lyon lens les pendules en trop
longs ou pas mais moi je ne croyais pas
du tout en fait
ben moi non plus ah bah oui on est bien
d'accord oui à boyle est pas là encore
tu t'es pas là alors oui oui moi je suis
tu je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
oui on est on est on est tous conscients
commence à bien faire quoi ceux qui se
lèvent pendant les matches ce qui ce qui
arrive en retard hockey bonjour ce quoi
a boy je suis 100% d'accord
d'ailleurs la prochaine big spring cup
ça va être terrible ça ça va lancer les
pendules à moins de rugby de retard
c'est terrible mais bon ça va maxime il
est tranquille il arrivé tranquillement
il doit avoir son petit et la wii non il
doit être pas mal mais pas même le seul
problème il a peut-être pas son
téléphone avec lui sinon sinon il
pouvait voir des corps ait pu lancer
quelques cas qui quoi quelques cas qui
quelques branches quelques micha j'ai
retrouvé mes baskets il ya pas longtemps
kevin alors elles sont toujours au tir
autant mordiller bah oui sont à moitié
sont à moitié mangé ça fait très plaisir
si tu veux ça fait penser à mischa tout
de suite mais j'ai mon petit
mon petit truc les chocs long terme
agents voient d'accueil du coup j'en
veux un peu de cas qu'ils envoient des
équipes et ça j'en vois un petit cri
corps quand même le cri corps peut aider
un le cri corps peut aussi aider maxime
jouons maintenant pourquoi j'ai pas vu
ce cri corps est-ce que tu l'as pris
chez lui j'ai pris genecor ans ben
alaoui c'est ça donne envie de sap
j'écris comme quentin krikor comme ça
c'est des jalouses
c'est ça le problème en fait quand tu
rentres dans switch au début les gens me
demandent pourquoi ça une chaîne et
après c'est ce qui t'as pas les imiter
tout de suite pas très bien quoi tu vois
les murs ont envie de participer quoi
c'était vraiment terrible ce truc de
twitch au début c'était vraiment ça a
vraiment aucun intérêt de base voilà il
ya josé qui dit oh le kaki c'est magique
bah oui oui c'est vraiment sérieux les
regarde beaucoup des mottes
en plus c'est à des immo comme
qualitatif quoi ça ah oui non trop c'est
très problématique tu vas mais même là
même le cri corps là je vais avoir du
mal quand je serai plus ça va krikor ça
va être complexe en fait donc et magnus
vient de se réveiller
ouais il vient il vient d'envoyer suis
en train de le rajouter donc ça va
partir pour que tout le monde le voit et
comme ça on va on va être bien
après j'ai l'impression que magnus il
arrive toujours pile à l'heure où un peu
en retard et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
cette habitude même en partie donc
d'être vraiment oui juste à tarif
vraiment enceinte et avoir atteint un
bon moment pour jouer dur à la fin c'est
pas kasparov qui faisaient ça aussi
parfois d'harry vraiment même même une
seconde blessure façon c'est sûr qu'il
fait des siestes à qui révise qui prend
juste ça touche vite fait pour être en
forme pylône n'a pas besoin d'être en
forme un catholique aide à 18 heures il
a besoin
enfin il n'a pas besoin d'y être à 17h55
mel b à 18 quoi est-ce que
psychologiquement aussi le genre
d'arrivée juste à l'heure ça peut ça
même si genre à n'importe quelle honte
et hyper content qu'il gagne du temps
enfin tu es hyper content mais là après
ça va là il est pas trop en retard qua
non et même pas du tout retard enfin pas
du tout les 3 3 minutes en retard 2
minutes en retard oui oui je la mets à
prix n'était peut-être pas réellement en
retard thaçi pas il a way non il arrive
toujours filet puis bon ok c'est
d'ailleurs t'as vu le tournoi dimanche
qui reprend avec mathieu et sébastien à
sitges qu'on parle de tournoi avant
avant le match ils jouent à sitges
barcelone mois normalement lundi ou
mardi
ah bah du coup ils seront ils seront là
mais je peux peut-être faire une petite
poussée ou voir quelques parties après
je ne sais pas exactement où c'est si
jesse est ce que ce sera très lent à ça
une heure une demi heure une heure ouais
moi je vais dans une demi heure au nord
de barcelone plus ou moins tu as
longtemps
bah non je vais je vais j'ai du boulot
en ce moment kevin jonathan davies
woerth pomme mais je sais mais j'ai
retenu fait tu refais aller-retour ou tu
as well as après peut-être je peux
rester toujours vite fait de quelques
heures mais j'ai refait quant à la fois
tu fais petit rock quoi s'il
probablement quand j'y vais probablement
ya peut-être un moyen que j'ai passe ils
ont commencé du coup bas attends ça à
l'instant comment ci commence à voir un
parti n'ait pas joué encore le premier
coup n'ai pas joué mais c'est parti
etienne
non c'est lancer des quatre pieds ce
apport sur aucune feuille ouais ça va
partir sur une grünfeld direct ouais
jouer donc sert que maxime va jouer son
répertoire un an ce match etienne même
si t'es pas au courant évidemment je
connais pas le répertoire de maxime
médard à quatre échecs
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu ça
ainsi à tanger non ok c'est quoi ces
cavaliers c6 ou c'est fou d'esat ici
euh ok on va faire comme ça en regardant
j'imagine tout 17 filets devraient faire
quoi d'arrivée 3way attaquer là et l'a
probablement cavaliers prend ses trois
filles en france et 3 et 5
ouais donc je pense que matthew a joué
ça les cavaliers 6,6 même un coup comme
calais prendre break et c6 qui allait
prendre un prend 2,3 peut-être bois des
jockeys et c6 ok c'était le choix car
elle est belle ce système quand j'avais
six essais par un pion à wasquehal b
saint clar là et besson qu'après c'est
bizarre ça c'est bizarre comme je vais
enfin ça fait tellement longtemps ces
trucs là j'ai dû regarder évidemment
mais qui je suis je joue pas là grünfeld
nathan boîte eut éconduit ce qui se
passe dans ces cas là tu le sais ouais
je connais je connais je reste oui oui
tu vas non mais vas-y fais effet fait on
fait t'on fait ton boulot
non mais en plus comme ça je peux même
vous ouais ouais tu peux nous dire ça je
peux juste en tout cas qu'il est prend
des cas c'est jouable inquiets brand et
katy et prend des quatre fous prend des
quatre cavaliers b5
il attaquera c7 turroques il comprend
des quatre il veut plutôt jeu faut
acheter ce nom alors qu'il veut fois ci
ce serait peut-être sur kelly prend
qu'il est prendre un point à kb simple
donc petit rock normal des cinq jours là
j'imagine ou même comme cavalier à
calais b 4 cavaliers à 5/4 et les
pédiatres et son groupe weight quoi
ouais c'est chaud c'est tout simplement
une position pour expliquer les enjeux
les blés blanc pris le centre donc ils
ont placé deux pions aux sangles et noir
ont pas du tout contester le centre pour
le moment mais en contrepartie les noirs
ont dû développement et vont pouvoir
essayer de casser le centre dans un
deuxième temps
ok donc juste pour vous dire les deux
coups son équivalent encaissé 6 au 17
la d3 il va
pourquoi y'a c5 qui peut peut-être
jouable surprise en passant pourra
reprendre du cavalier ou à 5
il a joué à cinq points à 5 sur a3 il
fait quoi cavaliers à six cas ici c'est
plutôt le taux à 5 ans général qui joue
pas c'est 5 dans ses positions passées
pas besoin de jouer ses six plus tard
oui pour casser le centre justement
ouais parce que hockey lah grünfeld tu
donnes le centre mais tu va l'attaquer
directement c'est l'idée de la variante
et en jouant ses 5 tu vois tu tu perds
un agent du fonds est intervenu casse
pour le cavalier ouais ouais à 3 to
belge etc et à 6 il peut sauter en c5
les cavaliers mevel il leur faut des
classes quand même si tu mets le puits
en c5
bon après c'est plus pour jouer ses
cartes et qu'elle et ses 5 mai ok alors
là est-ce que cavalia si ces forces et
j'ai ainsi que maxime réfléchi mais oui
le jouer assez rapidement tout de même
ok priori ce pion étaient comestibles en
d4 tellement complexe j'aurais pu
attendre de beit j'aurais pas le temps
de loeb deutsch mais il doit avoir donc
façon ils n'ont pas le droit d'être
dépendant à pendant l'heure et demie la
nappa noir et oui pendant la pause oui
mais pas la d'exact exact ce qui est
logique qu'un d'ailleurs ce qui est
logique
ouais c'est plutôt sympa et après
peut-être que pour les trois minutes ça
peut être important
et d'ailleurs à temps je vous dirai ce
qui est est ce que magnus a déjà joué
dans vingt quatre
il ya eu très peu de parties avec des
maquettes j'ai très peu de parties mois
il ya eu rackham 1 rakhmanov artemiev
alors vlad magic rakhmanov c'est un
joueur très intéressant à suivre pour
les ouvertures il m'a dit très créatif
et très bonne idée pas toujours mais ok
là pour le coup il a joué ça contre
savchenko s'il n'ya pas très longtemps
ok ok
j'écoute qu'elle ces cinq dames série 5
et le cavalier mvl qui va partout en
fait alors en b3 faut faire gaffe 1
parce qu'il est beau visuellement mais
en réalité ils n'attaquent pas grand
chose enfin peut-être pas le
le monde quand même déjà il peut
retourner en à cinq rouges et quatre
mois bref où j'ai quatre façons pour
commencer un ce cavalier anhalt en
regardant b3 il peut aller en d4 tu te
rappelles des partis au maximum 1000 cas
de l'iran 1
ouais ouais il peut il peut faire un
truc contrôle des deux aussi un petit
peu on sait jamais quand il part et
peut-être le événement qui peut revenir
par au sénat ah oui si tu arrives à m
une connexion entre les cavaliers là il
peut commencer ça peut ça peut faire mal
moi je trouve que c'est une position
maximas cas en ce début de match oui
complètement complètement bon a déjà ce
cheval qui a fait tous tout ce parcours
quoi il ya 6 b 4 6 et 5 baies 3 bientôt
bientôt l'autre on décède ces cinq
caisses
c'est vraiment parfait aïe aïe menace
peux tu as tu sais quoi fou prend et qui
est des quatre aussi huawei mais pas
tout de suite non tout de suite pas tout
de suite mais pas vraiment prendre
l'aventage pense je pense que l'ajout
pour avantage ou mais ou alors peut-être
aussi fou prend fou prend un cavalier c4
qui peut exister tu vois ouais moi
j'aime beaucoup ton ton idée du début
par exemple j'ai été choqué ses 58
alliés 17 après il ya peut-être
cavaliers prend 1,4 sur qui les 17 mai
faut prendre trois etc et des cachets
passer très très compliqué donc là avec
le bas sur mes mains et à peut-être le
fou prend vous prend et cavaliers ici un
ouais mais je pense que sur fouquereuil
joseph away écoute grünfeld a bien vu ba
qui est pour garder le contrôle sur les
cases
vous ne pouvez 3 c'est plutôt joli coup
et là il n'ya pas qui a et 17 à cause de
cavaliers prend 1,4 j'aime pas trop s'en
fout preuve 3 maxime salut tu l'a tout
de suite vu des reste encore un petit
peu que ça n'allait pas et que ça allait
pas bien ces visuels maintenant à est ce
que on jouerait pas un coup comme dame
du mali adame 8 mai date décès de soi
mais sur qui va lier prend 1,4 à 2.4
c'est pour ça qu'il a mais ici il peut
quand même faire c'est si je pense là
décès d'un homme prend en tout cas il va
falloir le tenter c'est sissaoui sur
cavaliers prend peut-être on peut faire
aussi quelques points 4
mais je veux dire là tu es obligé de
tenter quelque chose puisque h 4 h 5 ça
fait mal là et en plus si tu regardes
l'activité des tours blanches par
rapport au tour noire
ah oui c'est vrai qu'elles sont hyper
active en vrai donc là il faut ouvrir il
faut ouvrir d ouvrir 2 et 1h singh cours
à vendre mais ce crash simcoe avantage
c'est une pause c'est ça tu te prends
toujours dfk estime qu après j'aime pas
ça affaiblit beaucoup le roi là il a
encore un tempo à perdre ou la cime
corps alors samax il m'a dit qu'il est
même bien et on en discutait l'autre
jour il me disait quand tu fais aussi tu
laisses plus de choix et demi quand tu
veux ça q diego gas toi tu prends soin
tu prendras jamais et il m'a dit qu'il
aimait bien en blitz parce que ça
mettait à un doute il doit prendre une
décision coneway non mais il veut jouer
qui est des 4 ok c'est pas oui j'étais
plutôt pour ses 6 après je sais pas on
je vérifierai d'ailleurs je vais garder
je vais garder ses petits moments là
mais tu vois on entend discuter et on en
discutait sur le fait que s'ils avaient
le choix entre pouces et d'une ou deux
cases il préféré pousser deux quoi parce
que c'était plus fort sans way aucun nom
mais aussi ce n'était pas vraiment un
coup je pense mais c'est si c'était plus
fort que moi je veux pas tirer la prends
tes notes 19-18 c6 hop comme ça on
pourra lui poser la question après la
après les matches toujours intéressant
alors à chisinau
il va falloir faire mais là il est banal
qua non non ça n'a pas bien tourné cette
partie au 5 septembre échos je crois
qu'il ya un mauvais 1 mauvaise un chien
fou prend f3 était pas terrible qu'on va
partir de foot pro life 3 c'est devenu
dur auquel n'est pas finie quand même
parce qu'il ya quand même des pièces de
partout par contre les cases blanches la
wii mais il a eu ros eeles à lui qui
colmate est il à s'y prend il à la tour
qui vient recolle mater un petit peu
quoi il a gracié enfin avec 20 secondes
à la pendule
une erreur est vite arrivée ouais mais
c'est quand même discuté il ya deux
jours c'est ça mais il faut pas faux pas
qui loupe un ses débuts son début de
match
j'ai peur de d66 etienne parce que ça
met la pression ici ici ça met la
pression avec exercices il va pas jouer
assez prendrait six way qui tape avec
l'artisanat mais il n'y a pas le temps
ne regarde le roi de maxime
ok il a fait petit rock mais son roi il
est catastrophique par rapport aux
besoins métier qui est quasiment comme
en quoi le roi dans le centre hyper
protégé et ce qui peut avoir le temps
nous ok mais comment tu bouges avec les
blancs parce que si tu bouges le
cavalier du cahier des quatre qui arrive
bahia je pense qu'il ya pas de peut-être
fou des toits mais fou des trois
semaines as rien ouais mais un coup à tu
as des six il peut jouer comme des six
comme ça et que peu de temps ici puis on
prend 2,6 il va faire quoi il y en a
partout dam des trois cartels des 3ème
et des cinq à dessein car oui à
lecavalier en l'air un cavalier des cats
là il va devoir manquer des cafés lequel
a et b ci c'est très très très mal
placée voilà c'est dur ouais si bouge
adam dessin m'a tant donné là mesdames
et mesdames et j'ai peur de dame prend
ses cages pour ce que dame france ce
week end est pour france 3 france 4
france et catorive s'est demandé s'ils
sont leurs droits trop faible bon
c'était une bonne partie là de ma news
il a super bien joué
ouais ok bon aller roucouler ouais faut
pas faut pas le laisser à faut pas
laisser partir léger a sorti une énorme
part tient une fois le discours qui
comme quasiment comme côté magnus
ah oui là il a été monstrueux façon
c'est sûr qu'il prend maxime très au
sérieux mais non pas ok on en parlait
aussi c'est ce qu'il faut de la chance
dans ses positions pas clair en fait la
très mal tourner et si pour les noirs et
c'est au mieux pour les blancs et à
partir de fouet trois fois trois
sauvegardes est un très bon coup il faut
croire que c'était très grave à ce
qu'ils jouent et c6 ou pas mais
ok une petite espagnole des 300 en
général en général ça fait plaisir
ouais maxime qui les jouent bien celle
là donc food et deux cdd de toucher la
carte ra les bienvenus ce que j'ai fait
bien aussi mais bon en général pour
doubler de ça doit être pas mal fou des
deux l'idée de fous des deux là je ne
sais pas donc il va faire à 4 way s'est
jouée cette diagonale un petit peu quoi
tourbe et 8 prises prise
je crois que j'avais joué quelque chose
de similaire et a pas un tour à cette
dame a contre contre comment il
s'appelle quand il a joué contre
dingli-renault candidats oui il a joué
un coup un peu comme ça ouais il ya eu
un flux d devrait mais ce que c'était
dans cette position exactement ou pas je
pense pas je pense pas c'était plus loin
là je sais pas en fait je sais pas donc
le cavally et cavaliers au dos il part
vers g3 c'est une très bonne case g3
souvent on passe dans les italiennes par
des de f1 donc rejoindre tours et là on
passe par ces 3 ou de g3 donc il fait b
car sinon maxime menacé lui même b 4s
qui doit jouer tous ces quatre là maxime
pour éviter des baies 3 mai 3 c'est une
menace dont on dirait même si sacrifie
un pion par exemple kg 3 b3 fou prend b3
calais prend b3 puis on prend b3 10 ans
et 5 puisque sur faut aussi s'il y avait
quatre comme ça visuellement c'est leur
bien pour les noirs donc il joue ses
quatre meilleurs jouets il faut ici
j'imagine
ouais il faut aussi se moquer faut aussi
se fout prend 2,6 les changes défaut de
cases blanches c'est pas si mal pour ma
puisque maxime à tous ces millions sur
le plan câble
voilà la grosse différence entre dans
cette position c'est la force des fous
de cases noires oui celui de maxime est
beaucoup plus fort il attaque le pion b4
art que celui de saint caprais autour et
huit fois fuite est souvent j'ai c'est
ce que j'essaie d'être pour eux sur
glace fou et donc l'idée dont je parlais
tous les to race est d'amasser des idées
ou c'est moi qui divague
ac oui mais pas tout de suite là tu dois
déjà finir le développement cavaliers le
dos il
il est pas terminé tu doit empêcher des
5 c si ça a l'air d'être un bon coup
comme ça encore si ça a l'air d'être un
très bon coup est ce qui peut jouer dans
des quatre noms des quartiers c'est donc
le problème sur des prises prix c'est
que ça réattaque le fou en réalité dont
il fut le 3 mai sur des saints qui ce
qu'il a un tri qu est-ce qui veut jouer
cavalier promotion ouais c'est ce que je
me demandais ouais c'est exactement ce
que je me suis donc un truc mais c'est
là là c'est ouais là alors attendons
depuis on prend ces quatre c'est le coup
qu'ils avaient pensé six dames c'est 7
il veut jouer qu'il allait prendre des
huit qu'elle prend des huit dames prend
b8 bref au procès cinq français 5
d'écart alors attends je vais montrer un
parce que c'est ces pros ça a
probablement arrivé j'avais peut-être si
on prend des trois intermédiaires ou
quelques pions sont puis on prend ça
change
ouais ouais peut-être que puis en france
et mis aussi bon va mettre la variante
km devrait arriver et la cites a joué
puis on prend puis on prend tu peux
peut-être joué flou messi soit c'est kg
3 ok c'est pas clair ces temps durs est
est ce qu'il ya une autre idée parce que
magnus réfléchie est ce que sur puis on
prend cavaliers prend il n'y aurait pas
une idée de marloux on va voir on va
voir ça enchaîne les coups salariés
croyez qu'avec pardon ouais en fait
c'est la position
il n'a pas pris des poids coq est
magnifique c'est la position dont on
parlait etienne france et 5 français 5
essais content parce qu'après vous
baissiez s'il peut jouer qu'à et j'ai
trouvé sur trois des huit y la c3 c'est
pour ça que j'ai pensé qu'il devait
changer en d3 ouais pour pour qu'ils
aient plus les pions c est pour que le
pavé 15 12 après sur tour des 8 mai tour
des 80 ans du jamais vu et sur cavaliers
prend 1,4 dams et de jeu l'entrée
là faut que je bouge un peu les pièces
et complexe ouais c'est hyper complexe
oui d'ailleurs on va peut-être descendre
les regarde fouet f5 puis on prend car
il est j'ai trois et je peux plus
protégé ça non donc elle est mais c'est
juste incroyable ça je veux montrer mes
qualités à de calcul ok c'est tour de
vis de ça marche ici pour le noir c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment pas de bol
d'après tour des huit qui peut jouer 3
encore mais fou des 6 ha c'est la cata
ok 7 c'est vraiment pas de chance en
fait les deux fois la finale 3 1 il va
reprendre ses trois cahiers cat c'est
vraiment et même si ça marche pas
d'albert du coup ouais mailhac et des
deux mers j'ai pensé à la même chose
mais la fourchette mais dont la cire 6 3
qu'il prend 1,15 dams et de fouet f5
ouais mais d'ailleurs surpris en france
est cinquième tour d2 ouais ok non mais
kg 3 surtout ouais c'est vraiment ce qui
se passe là c'est alors à tanger
peut-être cinq encore il a fait froid 15
en fait réussi à y demeurer 5e 3 j'aime
mieux mais y'a food et si cela est
surtout des six je pense qu'il va jouer
kg 3 mon sac
il va 50 il va donner ce pion mais cet
échange deux arrêts pour garder parlait
en fait il a absolument besoin de garder
4 des quatre façons il n'a pas eu 5 g 3g
3 c'est alors à temps il peut kg 3 y
avait peut-être h5 aussi à temps il peut
faire d'amr est ici coup de marloux
parce que tu protèges g3 est une menace
j'aime pas ça pose pas je déteste
ouais parce que là même les fous
bessette tu vas te prends des sacs assez
catastrophique
marc en réalité de matériel ces deux
fous contre une tour et deux pions donc
déjà c'est un peu mieux pour les noirs
matériellement même si c'est pas énorme
énorme mais
truc c'est que le roi blanc est faible
et que ça joue sur des diagonales et pas
sur des colonnes non mais là on a
franchement on a vraiment manqué de
chance à temps il a raté trois à cinq
magnifiques à saint maximin c'est bien
joué des tours à 5 c'est bien joué parce
que regarde y'a papa car ali hafsi sa
ds5 qui traînent tu dois faire g6 ok
c'est pas ça change pas la face du monde
mais quand même tu es content je pense
vrai t'es content mais tu hésites et
quand même mentir encore moins bien et
moins bien mais
mais tata tour en a cinq étapes tête un
jour non mais tu vois tu sais pas je
sais pas je sens que c'est tout rang à
cinq elle peut faire quelque chose tu
vois fou bessette a peut-être des
tourbes et 5 tout d'un coup dame b enfin
je sais pas c'est assez clair non mais
c'est clairement une petite avancée mais
ça reste vrai mais regarde le temps
regarde le temps baky c'est maximus
quand même avec les blancs a les bras
qui croient encore à l'eba qui on y
croit voilà comment ça peut tourner un
petit peu je veux dire vraiment ces deux
moments là dans l'est dans le milieu du
jeu ont été incroyables donc il faut que
ça tourne
il n'y a pas un tour f 2 bêtement avec
des cavaliers f quattro tu vois qu'ils
partent way to have them v6 pour c'est
plutôt bien pour les noirs d'avoir dès
qu'elle est la tour on verra un dame b 6
dames 1 j'y crois pas qu'ils j'y crois
je suis dans la rue il va la gagner
celle-là je la je la sens bien
oula vous 17 ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
ça c'est sûr que c'est sûr que c'est un
mauvais coup a ajouté cette femme
mauvais c'est sûr que ce n'est pas
optimale ah ouais non c'est très bien
parce g4g 4 pomone g4 au web ce qui peut
pas faire cavalier 4 c'est l'idée qu'a
eue prend f4 on attaque la dame c'est
pour expliquer cette hausse inco
peut-être ouais c'était l'idée et après
dessine co où l'orage trois relais
attend si je le prends juste non je
pense qu'il va me prendre
car oui je sais non ok ça c'est le truc
qui me faisait peur mais j'espérais un
tour des cinq ici un megaman f4 tour
prend dé 6,2 me prends des 6 e 5 est
prononcé sur échec maintenant quelle
horreur c'était toujours sur échec à y
avait il y avait toujours il y avait
toujours eu échec avant discuter de la
main
avait compliqué sa position je sais pas
irréfléchie quand même moment où est
vrai c'est peut-être restait mauvais il
à deux doigts là il à deux doigts il a
deux doigts baki ça a failli tourner
méthane best-seller très très fort oui
j'y crois encore fait des dames un tour
à 6 tours je sais pas aller voir quelque
chose là mais t'as pas un gamin tour à 6
c sur dame c'est cette 5e médaille f4
oued à machiavel et f4 elle peut être le
socle ouais ouais ok demain c'est un
très bon courage aux tirs et du cavalier
des trois ou quatre jets d'eau tout
reprend à chiens ou là et e5
c'était l'homme voilà c'est un petit peu
extrême web iphone 4 ouais je crois
qu'il a raté faux h 4 c'est terrible à
tant est ce que c'est si terrible que ça
ouais c'est terrible ouais les terribles
ça la tête ça non il n'y a plus rien il
ya dame b 1 qui arrive c'est horrible
quatre étaient ouverts la loupe et
d'anne decis tour f1 dame c2a il peut
plus défendre ni almaty si je vais faire
cavalier deux probablement mais ça va
rentrer avec tours b 2
donc allez faut essayer de lutter
etienne ouais enfin là on recule
il va abandonner huit tours j'ai deux
dames bedouet terrible faut prendre
froid qui va arriver c'est joli bien que
magnus
ouais 3h 5 machin et tout ça a été la
dernière
la dernière goutte d'eau ça fait déjà 2
0 il fallait pas jouer j'ai 4ème c'était
tentant un sujet 4 après il a tellement
bien joué et il retourne là dedans
maxime qui chantent jouent le coup des
sept voiles et il avait les deux coups à
23 donc c'est ce que tu avais vu dans
les partis qui ont déjà été joués je
veux que l'ordi données de notre hub h45
pour jouer carey db4 probablement est
menacé car ils essaient de sa force que
vous alliez prend des 5
c'est pas mal son coût à 5 j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup son cou jusqu'à h 4 h 5
h 6 il a pas encore roque est allé là
c'est hyper important de recoller 1 à
dallas 2-1 l'a directement non mais à 5
super court mais très bien joué vrai ce
que les h5 hockey par exemple qu'il
prendrait 5 pourpre en achetant un pc 6
c'est magnifique pour les noirs c'est
marrant parce que c'était la prépa de
manu si on est à 5 tempo à wimille août
cavallieri non c'est très bien joué à
québec et peut-être de métro encore nous
qui fait qu'eric arrêts d'assises pour
envoyer l'autre cavaliers en b quattro
qui a peut-être qu'il est prend des 5
200 dessins hockey dont le style
scandinave la wii mais scandinave très
réussi côté à côte et maximus ici ouais
non mais pas mal pas mal parce qu'en
fait ce h 4 h 5 comme t'as pas fait
petit rang qui les pins après sa
précédente
ce qui me rassure un peu etienne c'est
qui perd pas comment dire il se fait pas
massacrer en fait c'est juste deux
positions qui tourne compliqué qui
tourne mal en fait
non mais là le tour des huit c'est juste
incroyable oui oui bah oui c'est
jusqu'au terrain autour des 8 c'est ok
au début ça a l'air pas clair presque
mieux pour les bleus après tour des buts
c'est presque notre engagement
ouais bah oui c'est pour ça que marche
james patrick et g3 y avait acheté 5 en
fait au lieu de songer 3 oui évidemment
songé cats après été mauvais mais auquel
d'un v6 est louable
bon allez là sinon mais les deux voies
la dame b 3
ok pas de façon ça peut pas être bon
d'avoir fait un b3 damas trois dames à
trois dames b3 ou coup de coude
d'hamelin ya beaucoup de maïs donne donc
j'aime bien à 4 est ce que tu penses que
maxime s'il réussit à installer quand
même beaucoup de combats tactiques comme
ça il peut user magnus bas à 0 2 non il
peut pas le musée mais s'il revient j'ai
réussi à maintenir ouais voilà il est
devant ses positions c'est vraiment moi
il faut un petit coup de pouce du destin
ou quoi ouais voilà un peu la réussite à
l'esa là elle est vraiment très
importante je pense parce qu'il est
mieux faut pas qu'il la rate d'amd 6
c'est bien joué
est-ce qu'il est mieux je sais pas mais
en tout cas il a une position jouable
enfin il est dans son schéma quoi il est
dans son schéma aller moi aussi je bois
un petit peu de modes de bab al oblige r
wella il nous faut un peu de force
il nous faut un peu des mots tu là je
pense qu'il nous faut un peu d'émotion
le chat oui oui je pense qu'on voyait un
peu de bab jeu parce que tu en penses
six cavaliers ou quatre jeunes avait
quatre chèques
ok j'en vois quelques baies ap à temps
pour son détendre l'atmosphère
[Musique]
allez y à un mur qui part et un petit
mur qui part fois m6 qui aura lieu 4
voie mais peut-être la finale elle n'est
peut-être pas clair dans le cas des
chèques afu des deux peut-être
simplement crise avait cavaliers b4 non
c'est pas si clair ou et 6 6 1 4 6 4 ans
et 3 ou 5 3 j'en sais rien c'est le
terme des six était quand même pas elle
avait une bonne tête en fait mais
peut-être pas peut-être pas très cahier
mur tu as quoi est ce que tu veux dire
je vais bien à 4,71 points 4 temps à
temps ses pages ff6 e4 more4 de 4 4 à 4
oui d'accord c'est bien joué parce que
sur dame c2 est fait il veut faire du
québécois trop en premier et peut-être
oui d'amd inquiets prend ces trois
objets taipei par magnus ouais il a raté
donc mais après cavalli ou quatre ça
ressemblait à mieux pour lui blanc
qu'elle donne b4 des deux battants dame
ces deux ça donne quoi comme ces deux
cavaliers même cavalier db4 non ouais et
dames des à ce moment là on prend des
coeurs il faut prendre des quatre epr en
d4 dame prend des katas me prends des
quatre qui essaient de me fourchette
royal pour récupérer la dame alors qu'à
québec 4 il veut jouer donne des deux
fous prend des katas 3 le hockey si ça
marche c'est encore je montre un quai si
ça ça marche c'est donc à savoir si la
science fiction que ouais y'a rien à
faire même les fusées même les kakis
même les gardiens qui pourra marcher
aujourd'hui ça c'est de la science
fiction si ça marche
il a fait cas les français 3 des
français 3 et le 5 mai il n'avait pas le
choix
sa démarche est vrai
je le vois sur la caméra qui les a je
suis assez en forme tactiquement
aujourd'hui mais j'aurais préféré aurait
préféré qu'il soit pas en forme du tout
et qui est tout l'image se leurrer c'est
la cata baky qui voient tous genres du
si baghi qui aurait battu avec leur
audimat ici aurait battu magnus 10 0 ce
soir
bikey dans la meilleure forme de sa vie
oui ben qu'oui maxime a vu que cavalia
des quatre marches cavaliers db4
marchait pas mais on joue en un 4 mai
mais même en longue d'ailleurs été
dégoûté si ça marche pas non c'est une
si longue variomètre avec quelques coups
avant en fait oui oui ils goûtent et ça
marche pas mais tu vois là non non tu
l'as vu quelques coups avant mais tu te
dis quand même c'est de la science
fiction que le mec qui laissa même en
longues en fait oui oui taye taiwo il
trouve un coût que pour continuer la
partie mais il est bien beau teigneux
oui mais regarde 35 secondes
ouais donc ça je vous 3 minutes 30
secondes
ok ça passe assez bien joué la prison à
6 et le rock parce que du coup je fais
petit rock avec les noirs il va te
prendre 5 et il va toujours les cases
noires mais quoique la sueur
pas sûr puisque la taxe pl wahiba use
raid 5 ouais mon nom me wade joue pas
débutée il peut pas prendre est par
contre il va falloir se dépêcher de pas
échangé ce coup je pense que là le décès
quand même des fois je suit genre ouais
mais après des 5 es fou b2 mais bon y'a
pas un petit juste pour expliquer un ce
pion achi c'est très pénible ce qui crée
des réseaux de maths et c'était l'idée
de l'avoir poussé jusque là et c'est
quelque chose de difficile à gérer
tu vois jouer des secours au 17 mai la
ouais c'était soins ans prenait les fous
de couleurs opposées et qui était
terrible avec la taxe sur le roi noir
soit on va se prendre bientôt les
changes de foot cases noires qui n'est
pas pas beaucoup mieux
alors elle doit absolument éviter un des
5 fu et 2 maxime vraiment sur des cinq
as fou prend a donc ça va
et surtout bedoya fou prend le 4 et sur
cinq
il clôture la grande diagonale et mais
il joue cavalier ou cinq fois et
j'allais en parler parce que les donne
aux pions mais dans ce cas-ci prise
prise prise il ya foule des deux dames
ces trois cavaliers 5 c'est encore un
coup les joueurs de l'espace est ce
qu'un fou g5 est possible et non parce
que tu échanges
oui c'est possible mais tu échanges les
fous de cases noires t'es pas content
bcf carrick et fourbe et sonne bien joué
ça joue encore sage ou encore parce que
parce que justement il n'y a pas d'
échange de pièces est ce que on peut
tenter à je pense pas que ça à jouer
tintin d'amalfi jay 5 mai annonce a pas
marché
tourbes est encore bien joué il est fort
un tempo sur verre adri surprise on
trouve tout reprend pions prend tout
reprend juste pour montrer à on protège
latéralement le cavalier e 5
c'est pour ça que je dis très bien joué
tempo c'est surtout tempo moi je n'ai
pas vu venir
j'allais dire c'est çà ou là c'est loin
d'être un bon coup qu'est-ce qu'il est
fort magnus quand même étienne ces îles
et il est vraiment impressionnant ce
début de match 1 le champion du monde
norvégien voilée il faut qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un petit retour à 5 tours
mvl touraine torah 5 extraordinaire
aussi un peu tourner ça peut faire
changer le match prise et il va
reprendre cinq noms alors attendre mais
il est pas trop ces 7 mai atteint damas
cinq way voir des trois peut-être voir
des trois intermédiaires des trois fous
prend le 5e français deux tours prend b5
nous vous proposons un tour c'est simple
c'est l'enfer auprès d'un match sans un
seul coup du coup dame g5 aussi posé
adam g 5 pour pousser 6 elle vaut quoi
la finale après fou ces six mois ça va
pour les noirs je pense
bref tu as mal pour une fois ça a bien
tourné voilà bras une fois ça a bien
tourné
ce cafouillis fois ce mois-ci à pour
garder du ferret 3 détroit ok pas de
finale mais pas de finale c'est à double
tranchant
ok mais deux mandats vendu ma news et
comment tu vas faire avec trois secondes
à la pendule allez faut que maxime soit
malin la halle et le marlou
en une petite déco ça ferait pas de mal
donc je ges
adam e6 mais oui il tient le premier
point du joueur français
la déco c'était des communes
investissent en fait il avait prévu fou
g5 et maxime lui a fait 1 dames 6 marlou
au lait de noix et clairement il a eu un
problème de coût je sais pas si un
problème de coût ou pas mais en tout cas
c'est une victoire pour la france a non
on des trous à la faute
tu penses y aurait 80 et le math de
marloux ah oui
3 il était à trois coups de mots t'es
bon dames c'est cette dame c'est cette
ça a été joué
c'est dans l'esprit de ce que lui avait
joué arte n'a fait mieux ouais ouais
c'est ce que j'allais dire j'ai cru voir
ça enfin il avait joué avec le pion des
quatre artemiev en fait il avait eu
quatre c6 des quatre des cinq et
cavaliers des deux d'avancé 7
et là tu vois il n'y a plus il n'y a
plus la possibilité du match parce qu'il
ya d'abord ces sept qui protégerait des
cistes arriva du jeu il fallait jouer
cette structure nombreux là il va jouer
j'ai trois fous j'ai deux je pense
ouais ça va ça non pour les blancs
fausser la visuellement ça a l'air
d'être mieux que les que les autres pas
que les autres dans le même style à et
d'un mode deux échecs la haye avant
j'aimais bien dans le 2 adam de moi
aussi j'aimais bien pour vous la petite
finale
ouais faut pour poser une question l'art
est ce qu'on peut faire juste tour on
accueille des deux à oui c'est bien
qu'ils avaient des deux à weekend c'est
4 x 4 oui une jolie d' ça c'est une très
longue et ça c'est joli ça je vois il
nous fallait ce petit coup de pouce du
destin
on en avait besoin il a pas eu de
réussite dans les deux premières il
fallait quand même un moment donné que
ça tourne un peu quoi c'était pas
possible vous aussi si tu vois il
n'empêche que ces quatre où il donne le
fou au pied ce magnifique sa caisse
assez rare contre encore on a encore le
cas de tout à l'heure et donc
probablement il va jouer qu'elle prend
des six daims prend 2,6 et maxime doit
éviter un fou des 5
il doit éviter les échanges des fous de
cases des cases blanches aucun s'était
toujours c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils
regardent c'est peut-être pour ça qu il
leur tarde d'ailleurs pour avoir son
cavalier il aurait dû le prendre ce
n'était pas une bonne
retardée j'ai pas compris
enfin fallait poser quand même deux
secondes peut-être après ouais oui il
l'a retardé pour éviter les fous des
cinq les machines mais là il fait quoi
d'où il a peut-être joué un peu vite ce
que ce coup après il veut je pense qu'il
a commis là gagner en mettant la
pression autant aussi lors de la partie
précédente il doit penser que c'est un
bon il a besoin de presser la pendule
c'est ça aussi où il peut faire mal dam
des deux mois c'est pas mal d'amis prend
b2 il à tour b1 et été reprise en v cet
enjeu les coûts joli coup de mou des
doigts il lit les tours c'est toujours
utile sur un fou dessin qui la c4 qui
protégerait b2 quoi qu'il arrive d'un
prend b2 tout robert dulas mentionné
c'est un joli coup ou des singes quand
je suis lancé le 4 way
je pensais que c'était le coup et si ces
caresses qui veut fou prend et cavaliers
ses cinq fautes trop intermédiaire mon
hockey n'a pas peut-être fut point est
fou c'est cinq sets pour ça ouais ok
commence parfois trois je pensais bien
jouer foudroyé tu vois là il continue il
joue vite un coup comme fou et 3 j'aime
bien quand même hein on lui dit c4 c4
qui avaient prisé foulée 4 way sli été
repris dans le chat j'ai pas le chat
mais j'espère que j'ai été repris sur
repris de volée sur cette erreur
tactique et maintenant il fait ses
quatre ouais ouais donc fouet trois
beaux bien jouer bref d'un boucher c4 et
surtout aussi cette maintenance au f4
d'un v6 et tu reviens dans le truc est à
éviter
pourquoi pas pourquoi c'est bien joué
c'est joué rapidement ce que tu veux
faire faut être quatre d'un bep 6 à 3
peut-être et commence à empêcher tout b4
préparer leur être là il faut jouer pour
des cuatro maintenant les décès des
cuatro alors b3 et jouber 3-3 et bien
c'est parce que j'étais pas sûr que ce
soit un très bon coup est justement à
cause de la synchro bekkat on à la casse
c 3po cavaliers mais dans l'idée
dans l'idée c'est pas mal il fait faire
à trois rabbins
mais là le problème c'est que sur des
cuatro il va y avoir du à cuatro aussi
donc ok ces voix là s'ajoutent vois ça
joue pour la bourse depuis l'ondé là
d'un côté comme de l'autre
c'est un peu quand même enfin mettront
pas au ski avec cette structure qui est
différente mais avec avec ce fc toujours
complexe en fait parce que c'est vrai la
question c'est si tu réussis à mettre la
marche avant tu vas gagner mais ça peut
être très difficile et tu peux même te
faire contrer avec les blancs moment
donné c est ce qu il peut jouer non
mesdames ces deux j'aime bien il va
vouloir mettre quelques tours et offert
fois tournée de gagner celle-là ça peut
faire suer magnus là encore une minute
d'écart
ouais il met la pression sur la pendule
ou hilarants remettre des fusées mais je
vois qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de fuser
dans notre cher c'est magnifique
là c'est un tournant du match déjà il ya
beaucoup de gens dans le chat un presque
6000 spectateurs etienne déjà ah bah
vous avez un match qualitatif là j'ai vu
qu'il y avait mille six cents personnes
au 1700 sur youtube donc on est déjà on
peut toucher les 10 mille aujourd'hui en
cumulé etienne sur un match comme ça
allait maxime tout le monde te regarde
on est un vrai tour des années les
débats trop là ils s'en prennent pas
vous avec le cse magnus des quoi tu vois
mais oui f6 cours watson qui règle les
problèmes 6 way et cavaliers des deux
mais ce pion f5 il est mal placé non en
réalité à il veut cavaliers visite qui
aura lieu 4
d'accord d'accord j'ai rien dis ouais
non je vais pas dire qu'il est mal
placée par contre pourquoi il ne peut
jouer que ces trois alors attendre des
cinq dessins qu'il est dur à organiser
l'ag vraiment une structure que je peux
avoir moi aussi mes dessins qui est dur
à organiser comment tu avances ici ces
cinq cavaliers d2 voire une raison il
veut venir en f3 et 11,5 laissera la
question food et 6 faut toujours
regarder les c5 dans ces trucs là il y
avait aussi les des 5
il ya aussi les 200 go mais là ni l'un
ni l'autre ne marche dans la nuit à
notre marché est ce que ça nous un petit
problème avec ce pion à 3 c'est ce que
j'allais dire est-ce que saddam avait
deux bus ou en c1 ou en b2
parce qu'il ya du f4 aulas qui arrive
attention attention je t'attends sert un
plutôt comme ça tu contrôles et ça et ça
ouais mais bon t'as tour indien à
cavaillon 5e pions bien non ils sac
paillassou b6 oui non oui j'ai parlé
trop vite mais je me comprends ouais
dentaire on s'est compris
en fait j'ai vu au moment où il a joué
oui mais oui puis elle fut proche c'est
tombé à l'eau petit fou mais si ce qui
fait plaisir mais là il n'y a pas qu'à
liège et 4 qui prend quasiment depuis on
peut donc ils le savent vraiment ouais
faut être quattro j'estime qu'au bout de
deux ans ils le gardent ces trois ans de
données
ok bon bah finalement d'un premier à 4 à
gaillac dame c3 est obligé de faire tout
reprend oulala ça j'aime pas ça ouais
y'a la colla nullité et permana ça en
train de mal tourner ça la voix ya
beaucoup de cases nous contrôler sur
cette colonne
c'est terrible ce qu'il a fait là
pourquoi il ajoute ces trois thèmes
adams et 3 était une fois au toit il
s'en est rendu compte 1 je pense à la
caméra ça se voit qu'ils à cvg pas je
vois pas vraiment moi j'ai la position
je vois pas trop ça tu vois tu es trop
peu trop trop petit mais ça s'est senti
j'ai senti moi aussi je le vends petit
mais j'ai senti que c'était pas des
douze qui étaient forts ouais ouais fou
des deux qui attaque et le pur à
certains fous et 4g cinq coups des deux
s'étaient pas moins bien pour les blancs
c'est sur la toit tout à l'heure je le
fous aussi si taper sur ces quatre baies
3 où qu'elle aille peu hockey n'ont
tourné tout comment il peut faire nous
faudrait faire un fou détroit après fait
un tour des 3 ou c'est bien joué ça
ouais la lime et les barbelés fouet fait
un tour des trois c'est très ingénieux
comme ça surtout reprend détroit et la
foux prend et bloquent la colonne et se
fout il est bien placé parce qu'il
renforce ses 4 enfin vous fait faire un
tour des 3
ça c'est excellent et y en a toujours un
point de moins bien mais très très bonne
défense là j'ai pas ouais là c'est les
barbelés
enfin si si tu trouves pas faudrait
faire tu trouves pas faux f1 food et 3
tu peut la perdre en 15 points
je sais pas mais très très dur à jouer
c'était très dur à jouer
là ça c'est juste égal non ça va aller
je pense à l'annoncé plus dur à jouer
pour les blancs ouais mais ok même si tu
te prends par exemple un dame f quattro
laptev quattro prise dame 17 je sais pas
peut-être pas mais ouais d'accord
le v6 d'amd cette voie mais b6 tour
d'air je voulais faire un tour derrière
là dessus
tempo avec maxime carrément il fait
carrément tour des noix est fou c'est 2
est l'un des points 4 peut-être ouais
même b prend 1,4 vous faut c'est de chez
pas au goût de tous ces deux jours et
joue exactement comme ça à y rentrer là
dedans ok ça il peut pas la perdre
enfin j'avais vu l'idée un joueur de
prendre l'an dernier j'avais considéré
que c'était juste mauvais pour les noirs
j'avais évalué sa comme avantage blanc
bat comme pas mieux pour les pas mieux
pour les noirs ça c'est sûr ce look est
à faire toi tu vas faire tourner
il n'y a jamais vraiment de réseaux de
maths en réalité il ya quand même tour
des quatre d'un premier set
non ok il fait autour de cette barre à
cuatro c'est juste avantage blanc ça il
a craqué dans magnus il y avait toujours
des cadres d'un premier set
un foot français qu'adams éviter
cherkaoui terrible mais bon tournoi je
sais pas tarif hôte le roi tu l'aimés où
tu mets pas en juin pour contrôler et
moi je pense que c'est plutôt égal je
pense pas que souvent tu as les
forteresses les marcheurs je vois quoi
non non il va pas la gagner mais
j'arrivais du bon côté de la nulle moi
je pense que les deux sont du bon côté
de la nulle en blitz il faut quand même
plus faire attention avec les blanco
mais en tout cas c'est mieux que tout à
l'heure
quoi qu'il en soit oui mais là il que si
je joue très très bien cette position
maxime il a une minute contre 17
secondes
ça va être ok allez moi je suis pour dan
biggar
des petits des skis truc là peut-être
105 ce que j'allais dire il met le roi
un peu en difficulté
il met la pression là ouais il va
remettre leurs enfants je pense nous
faut qu'ils trouvent une idée la dame 6f
quattro ok j'ai quattro mais là il
commence à être vraiment bien mais
malheureusement c'est une forteresse non
juste il peut pas rentrer dams et 5
assists peut-être là il va le tenter un
pari mais droit eu droit wade nord ouais
tout cas chaque coup il améliore sa
position c'est plutôt bien
ces cinq ou la c5 c'est peut-être juste
drôle drôle un an dans la tête a tenté
de jouer pour as his way va prendre ses
six pattes je vois pas trop comment il
peut essayer de gagner c'est un peu
bizarre ce qu'il a fait parce que c'est
même au risque et ce qu'il fait c'est
quand tu arrives en rep s'ils s'y
mêleront h7 en fait il va faire damas
bamba k
je pense madame points 4 9 points 4
tours processeur adam des quatre ou six
séries c'est vous qui aviez un joueur
qui arrive
oulala ok c'est chaud c'est chaud
bouillant etienne a laissé cette en même
temps il a bien fait de prendre le pion
je pense moment il part plus à laisser
encore une forteresse malheureusement à
mais il veut il veut monter avec laurent
f6 ou le marlou une forteresse ah oui
aya parois des quatre mesdames adapté 8o
commenté le roi le plan de marloux adk
3e 5 3 des 6 3 e cette dame a fui 3 3 et
6 mais cet homme est un génie ouais mais
bon c'est quand même je pense et
d'amalfi trois existants mais c'est
extraordinaire extraordinaire où l'on a
ou b alors la has qui lui a mis
extraordinaire exceptionnel alors ça
c'est l'extraordinaire etienne as well
as vous avez
ouais venez de vivre un moment de blitz
spectaculaire le plan qu'il a trouvé
quoi pour te mettre le roi m6 d'alger
cette non mais c'est top cet homme est
un athlète et on revient au score 2
partout comment il a gagné sa et
tiennent bon génie donc il revient de
partout ça ça fait plaisir
encore une une et savate zschokke côté
norvégien
trois cas les cas le retour il a été
fort dans la tête un cas et maxime là
pour revenir puisque contre le cours du
jeu modèle de la galerie essai fort et
après le plan qu'il a trouvé tous les
coups là les coûts de marloux les
petites non mais contre le cours du jeu
être mené 2 0 revenir comme ça est allé
jouer le gain est de gagner ça c'est
exceptionnel
aïe magnus qui donne les deux fous tout
de suite magnifique
il est pas bien la night show qu un
petit peu mais bon après eux
voilà un petit roi je suis tu donnes des
85 qu il met en rage sept hockey ahl et
d'amd ocho cinco par cette parce qu' il
ya des cavaliers ou trois qui est des
cinq qui traînait donc on perd pas de
temps alors pas on n'en voyait pas
sérieux et live sync ou assez génial
dans le trio est dans le chat est
fantastique quoi le chat sur czech comme
joueur même pas le nôtre le chat de
chasse comme il ya même plus les gens
qui parlent anglais quoi c'est que
maximise roquettes maxime le monstre
face et c'est exceptionnel qu à pas mais
j'y suis allé tout droit
g zoug of bin sa faille à tout qui va
partir là dans le tchat sur sur le check
point comme live c est terrible c'est
terry pourchasse comme ok cavaliers au
château qui est faux pas de chocolat il
a mis beaucoup il a laissé beaucoup de
trucs sur les cases blanches mais bon il
a le fond c'est 8 qui contrôle voit le
petit geste ingo il était un peu un peu
rapide
est ce qu'il va faire dame 8 et ont
peut-être même roy g6 ici pour h5 dont
il va faire tomber 8 déjà parce qu'il
doit le faire pourquoi il doit le faire
je suis pas principe de précaution parce
que de toute façon il va jouer le fou
des cinq minutes oui oui pour faire à 6
ouais il envoie g15
c'est quoi ça alors sur cavaliers prend
j'imagine que sa f3 et sur puis on prend
c'est aussi f3 sur un flux en france f3
aussi vrai puis on prend il va vouloir
damage quatre fous apsys ou g5 flash 4
quelque chose comme ça des surgit 3 mai
sur g3 c'est pas fou prend g4 et pranger
quatre dames j'ai cinq cavaliers h2 d'un
match alors sam arguments mais faut
aussi ce qu'est ce qu'il veut faire j'ai
trop il veut jouer la versys tout
simplement
j'apprends m3h5 parce que vous faire un
truc je sais pas ce truc de l'espace
c'est peut-être lui qui abusent
finalement voilà ça n'a pas l'air bon du
tout non etienne
il a fait un truc spectaculaire la
maxime je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
est ce que ce serait pas de nouveau le
retour de l'expression russe le vertige
de trop de succès g4 c'est pas un truc
qui marche c'est pas pour une seule
raison
tout le monde sait ouais parce que la
même après là il n'y a pas de joueur en
fait rien en fait suite aux magnus qui a
du jeu même mais bon ok c'est du blitz
ça peut h5 tour f 5 ou même f3 tourage 3
9 3 d'amada tour h3 et non c'est là
c'est un petit un petit accident de
parcours
il faudrait une belle déco la de magnus
pour trois minutes trente ans qu ce nom
là c'est être quelque chose bizarre hein
qui les caisses et première mauvaise
partie pour maxime du match c'était bien
jusqu'à ce qu'ils jouent g5 la whey le
g5 avec toi même la f4 il était pas dans
l'allemand dans ce genre d'opposition
faut jouer deux trois coups un peu
solide quoi faut développer des pièces
qui peut essayer de jouer fort aux
nuances a poussé fait s'il est à la base
et vous en avez vu des dizaines des
partis comme ça de sébastien bach il
peut essayer de jouer le blocus
j'y crois pas trop un majeur par là
c'est tout ce qui reste un comment tu
passes
s'il a le temps de faire tous rachetés
entourage 3f trois noms mais je sais
bien mais je leur parle accès c'est à
sale chance maintenant oui non mais il
reste au caisson foule à des jeux ouais
bah il n'a pas la colonne h ça c'est un
peu embêtant
par contre il veut jouer pour magnus
dans un tweet qui laisse faire c'est sûr
point f deux thèmes ailleurs à tour g8
c'est ça ouais ouais ouais dames m23
bouche d'un f4 tour g8 et touré fuite
du coup il faut trouver un coup très
très bien là tout de suite
est ce qu'il existe c'est ça la plus
grande question à dame 17 alors il veut
tout rêve 2 et dames g4 du coup
peut-être mais surtout reprend et fuite
il va être obligé de reprendre de la
tourner en bas presque six mois il peut
la finance de blocus et à raison ouais
c'est ce que j'allais dire est ce que la
finale avec les dames site échange les
tours escale est pas nul
ouais parce que l'idée c'est tout
reprend 28 tours prend la fuite après
d'alger cette tour h8 échanger les tours
ouais il faut être notre dame âgée de
rentrer échanger des dames mais c'était
charge des dames elle est nulle c'est
sûr donc y jouer
trois élèves 3 qui est un bon coup et en
fait pourquoi il a peu joué d'alger
s'est tu sais c'est l'erreur fatale g7
il avait une bonne chose mais aussi
jouets objets 7 oui sisiphe et dames g7
maintenant mais mesdames g7 maintenant
il ya tout rage 3 c'est dommage quand tu
me diras il avait peut-être torah je
crois quand même tout à l'heure à temps
et si je fais deux derniers sets après
ok y'a fouet savoir du jour comment
savoir est là il va jouer toujours 8 h 3
menace pause 6 il faut absolument le
couvrir sa tête il peut repartir avec
sigh prends parce que les six prend là
s'il n'y a pas de gain direct
il ya peut-être dû des cuatro là qui
peut faire très très mal les des cuatro
tourache fluide quand même tu es quoi
trop ça mais on peut être un coup un
couperet on peut être un couperet date
gamme avec quai mais ça ça ne te
découvre tu fais vous pourquoi magnus
parce qu'en fait si tu fais fou ici roi
et 6 tu fais rien ah oui là tu es là je
pense que il a des chances maintenant
parce que la foule à [ __ ] couleur
opposée à les 100% nul 1 il n'y a pas de
rupture finale de foot vous leur posez
ouais quoi que c'est pour ça qu'on a
essayé j'ai essayé de jouer des clac là
parce que les attaques
donc je le répète à chaque fois il faut
que vous mettiez c'est très dur de jouer
les fous de couleur opposée parce que là
si on échange tous nuls facile par
contre la moindre attaque c'est fini tôt
damages six dames d un fouet et 4 dames
b3 damage de en touche en premier oui là
on touche mon premier il prendra
d'autres non mais je leur parlais en
touche en premier c'est important parce
que si c'est lui qui toujours là et je
comprends pas que je comprends pas que
j'en vois pas plus loin encore des
barbeaux lettre bah oui vas-y envoie on
y croit que je passe c'est peut-être
qu'on n'y croyait pas c'est magnifique
3 il a défendu un truc un de défendre et
b6 maintenant il faut juste faire gaffe
faut faire pousser un fouet ce tempo
bien joué ya pas d avoir un chez maximus
way le plan le plan de ramener le roi
via 4 mars jamais parce qu'en fait on
bloque facilement
je peux même revenir avec le roi tout
simplement hou là tu peux même prendre
prendre fou ici c'est ouais attend
j'aime pas trop laisser ces chemins
quand même tu vois il fait baisser le
coût est fou des dossiers fouet est fou
c'est 5 et la ceni direct on sait assez
bien de retirer le pion b parce que
maintenant le roi prend jamais à cette
poussée saint pierrois g5 ok tu joues tu
as besoin de jouer ouais vous c-53 quoi
pourquoi magnus pourquoi tu commences
est même paroisse gc un curage qu'on
serait même paroisse g5
donc s'il arrive
ouais je vois pas comment ça peut
menacer de perdre il va faire froid f4
food et 8 en fait droit ces deux fous
des huit robes les trois points f3 roi
c4 tu prends tu fais roi ici et foulée 6
pouces et 5 juste à temps attend il ya
des 4,5 encore question non mais faut b
6 pouces et 5 juste il faut peut-être
sur des quatre fers fou prend son fils
ahmed voulais pas qu'ils prennent c'est
le truc salle avec le fond ans et 5 2
des cas tu fais des hits fait 1,5
un oui qui peut être un piège quoi mais
non c'était le voyais axima trop lille
il a même pas qu'il n'est même pas
protégé son pion allez on le tente on le
temps besoin il retourne là dedans
ouais mais après il était bien dans
celle là donc c'est normal ouais bon
deux et demi deux ans et demi mais
maxime la cette dernière partie elle
fait plaisir quand même s'il était pas
bien c'est toi nous bien monde mais en
ce moment je vais regarder il reste
encore 33 minutes le temps passe vite un
etienne quand on suit des matches comme
ça c'est pas un speech est habituel
ouais ça c'est au speech est au sommet
havas et numéro quatre mondial compte
numéro un mondial forcément ça envoie on
espère le prochain championnat du monde
oui et la finale la finale demain avec
uno journaux je crois en sponsor je
rappelle plus du nom du sponsor c'est
une joute au couteau peut-être mais mais
en tout cas elle sera une belle finale
avec avec hikaru qui attend de l'autre
côté qui a gagné un beau match contre
eux wesley 1 dans l'autre dans l'autre
demi finale
alors il a gagné facilement la dernière
portion c'est ça ouais enfin ça il a
fini avec un prix là il a gagné 13 12 1
au final
ouais mais bon oui c'était assez serré
mais assez maîtrisée quand même on
maîtrise mais mais bon je vais en parler
à quoi cela était la joue joue bien sur
internet et vous on replie de blitz
maxime qui a pas réussi à doubler les
pions cette fois-ci magnus qui a joué
car il est 17 avant maxime il a pas
obtenu
ce qui pousse qui nie la paire de clown
il a une très bonne scandinave
il a le ça tape dont je parle souvent
avec la dame qui est revenue ans et 7 il
faut venir en déficit vient sinon sept
ans plus tard la pas la flexibilité aux
petits fous des cuatro là pour mettre
des pièces un peu importe où il y avait
peut-être ces cinq sur food et quatre
non ok voilà il donne le fou tout
simplement il doit reprendre deux agents
français qui veulent reprendre de f
ouais mais bon ça affaiblit c'est
tellement les cases noires et ben ouais
mais il faut c'est être comment il fait
là comment il fait pour récupérer ce
faux on prend pas ok ça va je vais y va
jouer kg 3f detroit ont su un petit
poulain sur sur ces dernières parties
grand qu ouais mais ils jouent à magnus
qui s'inspire des meilleures mais tu
sais que quand il ya le pion h3 et tout
ça j'adore pour les noirs après
forcément je suis biaisé dans le sens où
c'est mon c'est ma manière de jouer mais
ça va vite de l'autre côté aussi sa vie
des deux côtés oui oui mais je remets en
fait c'est pour ça que je suis biaisé
moi j'ai tellement l'habitude de jouer
ça à côté noir que forcément au bout
d'un moment tu prend l'habitude depuis
avoir peur du tout cavalier le simcoe
oui
ah oui le joug savent visuellement je
suivais l'air bien ouais nan là là c'est
en train de vrais magnus qui essayent de
copier de joueurs français mais qui va
se mettre en difficulté
superbe lutte peu trop fort non mais là
ça va être salle parce que tu vas faire
faut prendre deux dames prend à dole qui
peut revenir en c5 la dame en f3 b5 les
canalisations d'échec quoi est normal à
la mc2 vu le p4 de maxime qui est très
fort parce que il peut mettre une pièce
en c5 et peut enfin ils menacent parfois
de mettre une pièce en c5 parfois de
mettre le but de jouer b5
il a mis une formation pions l'acquis
qui fait peur il ya dix ans le service
et si nicolas c'est ça fait mal ou là
oui il va y avoir de partout je pense va
mettre la dame en f3
le père bien placé avec décidé deux fois
6 tu sais quoi etienne fois ci si tu
l'avais ou parmi un grand classique
là il reprend ses 5 mais je veux dire tu
vois ah oui et non mais là plein là
c'est très très très dur à jouer
ouais bon oui voilà la loppsi ce seul
coup mais x 6 x 6 x 6 b 6 ouais ok on va
voir mais on tend vers vers les foudres
couleurs opposées l'un encore une fois
alors le seul micro problème c'est qu'il
n'a pas tomber après un coup comme qu'à
l'étranger 6 h quand j'ai su ça va être
la course mais je vous sais qu'à toi
parce que il a raison j'aime bien fou
ces quatre pouces et quatre c'est pas
mal
j'adore fou c4i dilatoire 500 à l'air un
peu forcé quand je dis souvent dans
cette position que quand il ya une les
blancs met une pièce en f3 que ce soit
ici une dame l'info c'est très chiant
parce qu'elle défend bien là l et al
attaques de l'autre côté ces genres de
théorèmes que je me suis fait tabasser
sûr que la dame noire elle est
uniquement défense la dame blanche
allait mieux lotis pour cause tu as un
plan qui pourrait être formé bon et dur
à organiser mais c'est tourer sim était
le foie en g2 aussi dans ses positions
il est terrible front g2 ils te voilà il
est bien il est bien où les fruits bleus
bien pâles en fait ils te blindes leroy
sur cette diagonale il attaque de
l'autre côté pour envoyer db5 c'est
terrible non mais là toutes les pièces
blanches ou un avantage par rapport aux
classements malévoz b5 au prochain je
vais lancer juste non je poursuis
vautours ou un toit tranquille il veut
il veut le faire réfléchir la fin il
veut jouer vite ça c'est sûr et mettre
la pression à ce serait bien qu'ils
prennent davantage en sept parties four
b3 à l'injuste et a4 a5 voit la foule
maîtresse là où x 6 à huy le fois ci ce
qui revient à willis est peut-être
cavaliers pro b sept cavaliers prendre 5
qui on prend le 5e tour des 5
ok pas de chance ok ça a été vu par
magnus bientôt plus qu'un imbécile bien
jouer sur football
17 1 maxime l'acquis qui se prend la
tête qui essaye de faire marcher fois ci
c'est clairement il va jouer ou
maîtresse à temps il faut à six
cavaliers de 17 fou prend 17 cavaliers
prend ses cinq tours france et
saint-renan c3 c3 pardon pardon vous
processus ouais je voulais c'est un truc
comme ça mais ba fo à 6 qui a aidé cette
vous prend v7 qui est français 5 france
et 6 donc ça va vérifier je pense que ça
pouvait marcher un carnet un petit peu
mieux pour les plantes
baky carnet à oui pardon il y en a
combien on a on est un deuxième partir
est 21 fois six cavaliers des seuls faux
b5 et c5 louise bessette
ouais ok bon après il y a clairement
penser donc c'est pas une
voilà ça c'est a mal tourné là il a
perdu son avantage
il abroge davantage mais pas plus il est
pas moins bien non plus quoi il a juste
perdu l'avantagent il a perdu l'avantagé
quand même très nettement
il n'y a pas un dommage 5 histoire de
clôturer la partie je sais pas comment
mais il va falloir le club des quatre
oui c'est ça c'est juste à les faire
annuler la dabka attend est ce que tu
sais que nous attendons ce qu'il fait
web ce qui a sans l'air mais et sur un
coup que même s'il faut il veut faire du
f4 oh ouais parce que la dame les deux
tours sont beaucoup plus forts que la
dame en gc 6 bien joué mais pions prend
on prend quoi ah oui où il a donné le
pion oui même d'un proche le problème
c'est qu'il aura pas de scission prend
tout reprend tout reprend tout reprendre
parce que tout redevient ça fait mal du
couloir à la fin ça aussi faut faire
gaffe c'est chiant ouais mais là il va
jouer simplement dû à cuatro ans oui oui
je sais bien les retours des 5
je vais juste dire qu'il faut faire
gaffe à ce à quoi on met autour des 5
dame prend j'approche cet état d'âme h 8
pour retoucher la rue en sens gamache
huit de devant où la maxime se présente
à tort est ce que ça veut dire sur h5
peut-être même coup comme ça car
jusqu'au 6 mais qu'est-ce qui veut
surtout reprend 1,6 pourquoi le fait
aussi strict à monsieur disent ouais ok
ce que j'aime bien là c'est qu'il fait
et il fait son truc c'est clair que
quand il joue quand son adversaire joue
le coup qu'il avait prévu ou tempo il
fait mal maxime quand il fait ça ouais
c'est intéressant ce qu'il a fait un
petit jeu près cela est-ce que tu prends
pas g6 qu'un passage parce que s'il fait
hk tu reprends aussi ce quand même avant
oulala c'est beaucoup de pions tout ça
mais ouais il était vraiment très mal en
fait magnus ok ok ouais mais a parlé d
une audrey ça commence à être
ça commence à être chaud et quoi tu fais
d'am-dam e3 où tu colles l'échec en
premier tu reviens de trois pages que
l'échec mais bon ce que tu peux te le
garder sous le coude pour aller rebondir
sur h5 un jour aussi sa c4 au site assez
croisée bien connu cet échec pour et
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi les
maximes il choisit toujours un truc de
marloux là le tour est vite de ma
cheville peut arriver à maxime il est
trop fort en fait comme celle ci c'est
tellement bien joué et oui et à madame b
6,6 à tour est d'amener devant tu là
mais oui ça ça peut tu sais quoi
il va le jouer je pense non comme des
cuatro ok faisons menacer maths en un
hoquet la tourelle et 45
et c'est bien joué et qui peu loin
autour de huit échecs dames des quatre
échecs magnifique d'un v6 tour à 8b six
tours de 8
il y avait dame c5 une cave et la finale
ah oui peut-être
peut-être peut-être pas si clair dan des
quatre façons ça transposant la cif et
tours 8 en vrai oui la finale a quand
même l'air tellement gagnante que je
vois pas comment ils jouent pas d'un pro
f 4 mois je serai dames 1re caté g4 en
fait juste vêtements ouais ou d'un
projet 4 ou d'un premier 4
il avait fléchi mais le joueur tour 8
d'abord qu'elle veut quand même mettre
le rang à 7 à roye c7 du coup bas à
temps il va pas juste se faire mater
après l'âme 17
qu'est-ce qui fait magnus seimat en
trois sets c'était spectaculaire
ça fait 3 2 pour le joueur français on
s'appelait pas décaler son roi là bas à
cause de la mort bis ils ont davantage
dans maxim de gala à les nouvelles
nouvelles ouvertures le dame prend des
quatre la csac over il va peut-être
essayé de lui faire un bep te la jouer
avec b3 foulée de ses pas je crois qu'il
faut clame un minus moins fort que le
français pour le moment à mais attention
le match est encore long et yen
nous ne sommes pas encore bien sûr j'ai
envie de te dire on est loin d'être sûr
non c'est sûr qu'on sera jamais sûr
après on as comme la peur du bullet ou
pas des 30 dernières minutes
ben écoute on profite déjà on profite du
match
non mais je te demande je te demande la
maintenance soit pour faire un point
avec avec les spectateurs du match de
ski à venir parce que je rappelle on
joue une heure et demie en 5 + 1 puis on
va jouer une heure en cadence 3 + 1 donc
3 c'est là il ya cinq minutes plus une
seconde par coup qui sont rajoutés après
chaque coup de chaque joueur dans la
deuxième portion aura 3 minutes au début
de chaque partie plus une seconde de
rage ou par coup et là est la question
que je pose à etienne c'est sur la
dernière partie qui durera 30 minutes où
il ya encore huit ou neuf parties qui
seront une minute plus une seconde donc
ça c'est une cadence très spécial est-ce
que c'est par la cadence ou magnus pour
être plus fort justement
ouais mais en fait si tu regardes les
parties la maxime joue quand même
beaucoup plus vite
c'est pas la même chose quand tu
commences directement du bullet ou caen
la france est là si c'est dans la
continuité comme ça on peut avoir peur
mais parce que magnus et a beaucoup
beaucoup plus d'heures de jeu que maxime
dans les parties de une minute bon à
noter que la cedh est parti de l'une
plus une qu'un moment c'est différent
c'est un peu différent et maxime joue
quand même très vite là il prend
l'avancé autant dans chaque partie
quasiment donc ok moi je pense que je
pense que finalement c'est pas si clair
après il faut quand même arrivé il peut
pas arriver en retard aux bulles est ça
c'est impossible il aura aucune chance
non mais s'il arrive après +5 et ça va
pas être si clair qu'ils soient plus
simple plus de voir même plus à 100% ça
sera ça sera pas bon parce que je pense
pas mais à partir de plus un ça commence
à devenir très très jouable bon il va
falloir que maxime réussissent à
maintenir les cartes sur magnus ça va
être dur hein parce que dans des matches
comme ça il y avait forcément des vagues
et tiennent aussi des vagues positive au
niveau du hall et on est un spécialiste
avec kevin du pur isoler ouais alors pas
mal de le jouer contre cette structure
avec ses deux souvent mieux que les
localisent c3 qui est passé bien en
place et c'est oui mais en contrepartie
maxime qui a pas réussi qui a pas le jeu
pour le moment sur sur f2 ouais mais il
a du fou des six alors tour se met très
bizarre parce qu'il est ce que les
processus c'est quoi ce coup tour ses
huit maxime pourquoi pas fou des six la
food & k tu as ça ça ça c'est ouais il
faut pas que là c'est mieux pour le land
à ses carnets de la ses carnets 1
c'est noté ça va être notés pourquoi 15
tours 6 8 alors à temps il peut
peut-être tentés alain cavalier ou 4
ouais je vais essayer joué depuis un an
c'est de là mais je crois que non car il
ya 4 qui apprend puis on prend fou prend
il va protéger les 3 comment il peut
elle est hyper fun pions parce qu'après
il faut problème si ça vous prend m6 y
aura les laisser daubé d'eau qui seront
en l'air ouais sûr c'est que voyez
bouche c3 qui m'embête
mais car les boules pour le mans il a
tout repensé de oui mais non mais doit
absolument jouer là-dessus aulas se joue
autour des deux joue autour des deux
tours de même peut-être ces huit
maintenant il faut peut-être mettre la
pression et tiennent sur j'aime pas
beaucoup le coup de magnus fois froid
j'étais plus pour foot est roi et jouer
pour le contre le pur isoler la ville il
va essayer de le prendre
pense pas qu'il puisse en fait autour
des 8
bizarre pour moi ce que vous aussi je
pensais vraiment qu'il avait joué tour
ses huit pour vivre à ce cavalier ou
quatre là son idée c'est peut-être tour
d un cavalier ou 4 car le calice prise
prise fou j'ai cinq attention oumar loum
maxime
qu'est ce que ces marques et surtour
détroit la fin tant français devrait fkl
mario français 2 quel niveau maxime est
acquis qu'il a vu baky en forme c'est
les kakis très bien vu pas qui est oui
mais c'est mérité fouet
3 ça devait être un mauvais coup ouais
mais fois le froid ce n'était pas
logique puisque le lot de la logique
c'est ce que tu disais c'était blindé le
pion c'est d'enlever le cavalier de
faire ces 3 et après de la galerie parce
que depuis le début comme je te dis est
le cas les c3 sa voix et sa case
après il ya peut-être un truc sur fuji 5
mai en tout cas c'est ça que tu as pas
fou 3 déjà fois trop il ya eu quatre qui
seront oui c'est ce que je dis oui tu
prends tu prends et tu prends le cas
déjà tard avoué troyes et tours de 3,3
et tour français 2 j'espère qu'il ya pas
de cool un fou prend ici à mon ami brad
mais je vais louper mais il ya du fleuve
5 ou du fou sexuelle 4 je pense vous et
quatre tours c3 on nous met quand même
par principe des barbelés si bien géré
mais quand même quelques-uns
maintenant il faut en mettre
quelques-uns tu as raison vous mettre
quelques quelques dents volé la norme et
maxime quand il joue comme ça c'est un
rêve parce que là il est il est juste en
train juste pour pour un peureux situé
aux gens qui suivent ou la projet
tu en prends des trois fous prend des
trois rois pranger cette tour prend des
c'est incroyable projet set ça c'est un
coup de pas de bol incroyable ouais donc
iran dans la finale mais celle là
ah ok estime qu à il est terrible francs
g7 la whey là on l'a loupé tout le monde
l'a loupé même magnus la loupe et il a
vu par hasard à la fin quoi je sentais
il fallait mettre les barbelés avant ça
a été un peu tard sur les barbelés mais
bon j'étais way et du coup cavalli ou
quatre qui marche pas mais vraiment pour
pas de chance et est souvent aux échecs
c'est comme ça by c'est pour ça ça
montre bien quand je parle du joaillier
il a eu de la chance où il ya de la
réussite où j'ai de la réussite ou pas
leur exigeant n'y a pas de repas de
chance aux échecs mais si l' on le voit
bien eu lieu
parce que là vous pouvez voir même n'a
que magnus il a vu vraiment derniers
mois et ça c'est clair
sinon il le joue avec le covan à thème
pour le faux projet cette wii puis en
peluche même je suis même quasi sûr
qu'il n'a pas vu le cavalier e 4 de base
parce que sinon il fait pas tour des
risques en paca radieux qu'a donc il
avait vraiment rien vu ouais mais c'est
hyper dur ok c'est pas des trucs que tu
peux prévoir en fait on voulait non
clairement annoncé sur son fouet froid
aux questions autour des deux tours d un
il était automatique est normal mais là
est ce qui reste une chance la part
active aux qu'il est fort dans ses
défenses de finale mais ça a l'air c'est
à dire ça à l'air très chaud entre sait
pas définir les habituels un ça va faire
qualifiées et aptes à faire un sa tape
avec food et 8
on va pas une finale habituel donc ça
laisse un petit espoir quand même fou
des quatre coups des quatre fous des
huit hockey ou bon l'idée simple de
maxime c'est le maximum des changes
depuis un an par exemple de fou contre
fout ça ne gagnerait pas pour les blancs
donc si on arrive à échanger beaucoup de
pions on va essayer de faire un
sacrifice pour cette génération qui veut
garder les deux fous sur l'échiquier
faire le barbelé
les fous qui tiennent les cases qui
laisse pas le roi rentrée sélection qui
doit échanger créer justement comme je
te dis à la fin il doit s il doit
sacrifier
donc ouais si les change pas de fou il a
plus de chances que l'on échange d'or
par contre le problème c'est que du coup
les fous blanc s'installer tiennent plus
un centre plein fer j'ai envie de dire
aux tenté un petit h chine colin sueur
fou bessat a foulé cette il veut y vais
encore prendre de l'espace hockey ou b
simcoe kobe s'il veut prendre de
l'espace c'est pas bête parce que soit
son style un pion en b3 et c'est
probablement perdant mais faut essayer
un pardon oui c'est très probablement
perdre en mai après tu sais pas ce genre
de position tu abandonnes tu vas bien
faire quelque chose de toute façon et
essayer couvrir non ok surtout en blitz
même en longue mais surtout en blitz
ouais non mais parce que c'est pas
vraiment c'est pas des finales très très
très facile en fait à gérer mais on
n'essaye pas elles sont patchés matic
quoi on les fout ok on sait exactement
ce qu'il faut faire marcher la de fou
auquel on sait qu'il faut en échange et
un mais on sait pas comment ou à avancer
le roi mais si les blancs avance le roi
il s'expose à raleigh va faire f prend
et voilà ce qui fait c'est bien air
france est bien joué et magnus il y les
joue bien aussi un maximum les défend
bien mais mais magnus les attaques bien
ses positions et s'est pas complètement
fini quand même faut deux c'est bien
joué mais à la question c est ce qu est
ce qui vole un fou d un d'avoir une
mille trous d un talent fou qui va
attaquer le pion h4 de l'autre côté fou
ses deux pouces et 2 il n'y a pas à 5,6
la foux pranger 5
il ya une petite présentation la côté
français tous asymco mais voilà bel et
bien la gagner maintenant bien la gagner
il ya une grosse présentation la côte et
maxime en défense tim cook
moi j'ai 4 5 et points ils mangent h5 au
kef où d'eidos fou des doses froid ici
foot et à frencq nous projetons calais
il faut croire bref au projet 5 et ça va
être bon il va où
ou même fou pranger cinq ans fait
etienne ah non on veut pardon fou un fou
prend h5 et après fou des deux fosses à
roanne ans ça va défendre sa défense
parle on est comme comme comme dit avant
bas on va sacrifier le fou sur le pion
voilà un projet 6 3 7l 6 oui pardon
sacrifie sur l'option magnifique défense
de maxime branche halal est très facile
enfin très facile non pas très facile ce
modèle à nancy il a posé des problèmes
pratiques et voilà non je vais repartir
d'ici c'est très facile parce que tu
mets le roi ambiguïté c'est fini le roi
devant le pilot bike fait une mission au
roi sur cases noires c'est fini a même
plus à jouer à leur niveau c'est très
possible
pourquoi est ce qu'il n'a pas fait roi
des 8,3 ses 8 3 b beady eye bon c'est
pas grave il y arrive mais là faut
prendre b5 et roye b 7 à 12 soit at il
suivi le cours sont étendues à la nuit
clos et non au kebab elle défend ce
graphique
allez maintenant faut lui mettre la tête
sous l'eau il reste combien de partis là
kevin attends je vais checker le temps
il reste onze minutes 05
donc il reste une ou deux parties max ok
faut le gagner
ouais donc du coup il a changé il a
changé magnus il est parti pour pour la
sicile années peut-être pour ses cheveux
schennikov mais du coup il a changé son
fusil d'épaulé la chaussure gilles
maxime l'a pas laissée faire lui tend un
petit fou b5 rosso limo ça s'appelle
rossoni mot ouais tu connais pas et du
coup j'ai six mois si on en a joué
mercredi
je crois qu'on a je crois qu'on est un
petit raid de sardes auch je suis pas
sûr donc merci à lui si c'est le cas
puisqu'on est 11500 la etienne dont on
comptera merci à lui désolé encore
maxime on est on est on est happé par
par le match donc on est complètement on
regarde pas trop ce qui se passe autour
les parties sont complexes mais les
merci en tout cas et donc peut-être dû
probablement la dernière partie si elle
dure etienne de cette cadence 5 + 1
franchement ce serait bien que tout peut
tourner à plus 1 ce serait bien ouais
ouais là plus de ce serait mieux
alors attendez quasi à trois cavaliers
sekkat je suis pas complet inès qui
risquions sur des quatre il peut se
prendre prise prisé des saints c'est ce
que j'allais dire ou es obligé de jouer
détroit et son cavalier pas très bien de
la séance les cas donc tu as raison il
va jouer le réjouit le plus sain qui
fait à quatre ils stabilisent cam le
cavale mais oui là le pion détroit qui
peut être arriéré etienne ben là on est
typiquement dans une position destin
diène destin diène g3 à verser parce que
maxime va jouer g3 il faut probablement
et ouais c'est un peu mieux pour là
c'est un peu mieux pour les noirs ont
avec eux puis on en rirait en d3 tu peux
jamais joué 2d car il va taper dessus
avec tour des 8 etc
ces chiens sécher le carillon c4 la case
c4 qu'on pense pas du tout à risque de
caillot 3g demande est là est-ce que
c'est pas une opportunité car l epr en
pions prend et des quatre fonds prend à
taxer 5 et bien car attaqué à mes
tournées 8,7
mais des cas tour des huit clouage et là
faut trouver un bon coup à des cas
priziac elle atteint surya cape may à
cavalli b5 chif
c'est au tour des huit qui a et b 5 est
sûr qu'être en d4
en d4 sur d8 il faut trouver un bon coup
ça nous prend des cas ça m'a l'air de ne
pas être vraiment mon mieux ouais et
puis on prend je pense que c'est mieux
que vous prends et je suis d'accord avec
toi et c'est ce que maxime a fait
peut-être dame f3 maintenant ouais il
assez d'activités normalement pour
égaliser
est ce juste pour des régions damev 3
y'a pas le pench la ds5 aussi est ce
qu'ils pensent les u15 prisé damas
quatre ouais c'est bien joué ouais non
non ça va aller mais par contre c'est à
dire que cette partie peut se finir vite
et qui peut y en avoir encore une autre
dans la cadence parce que attends je
vais se finit vite c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle ça veut dire qui se
répand souffrance parce qu'il reste 7 7
50 je pense pas que cette partie dure
encore 7050 etienne non c'est une bonne
nouvelle au moins on aura une partie de
plus un jeu te dire des matches comme ça
ouais mais tu de toute façon après sa
recherche
sarr change de couleur et tu fais blanc
noir blanc noir donc est biak et noir il
n'a pas vraiment eu de soucis donc ok
j'ai envie de te dire que c'est vrai
pour maxime vu que en 1 + 1 c'est
l'autre qui est légèrement favorite
peut-être plus il ya de 5 + 1 et 3 plus
simple mieux c'est pour max ouais alors
d'amd si c'est ce qui doit s qui peut
jouer damas quatre faut quand même un
peu défendre là il prend ça fait quand
même 2 par 2 2 3 parties là que maxime
doit défendre etienne tout de même bah
ouais mais bon s'il défend tant mieux ça
veut dire quand tu vas voir l'avantagé
il va pousser mais ya pas beaucoup de
lui si si si bon là il ya des signaux
prochain couvent sur fou aussi j'imagine
de sinko ouais tu es tu vas et changer
ça et ça contre ça et ça peut-être fou
et quattro ici peut-être des gosses
attends attends attends attends
y a pas pris 1 prise prises sont pas
aussi de 6,6 ou est ce que j'allais
c'est pour ça que
j'ai du mal à y croire mais il va
enfermer la tour sur cette dame c3 dans
ces trois dames des six bons retours ce
sont tous des tours 1 attention non non
je tapais peut-être pas mais c'est très
important peut-être dame f6 etienne du
coup comme ça tu l'as déjà mais toi tu
veux jouer le matelas au cas ce que je
veux dire oui oui mais là c'est ben arfa
sont là c'est le prochain coup va
décider de la partie où les deux
prochains savoir ce que dit le redis je
leur disais je vois venir avec ses tout
roule alors dit des tests ou là bas
décidemment ça va être autre chose de
trucs ce que dame 10 dames v5 est sur
toi tu as fait très peur là même du tour
à deux tours à skis veut pas du tout
reprend pions prendra me 8 roi ici dame
ec3 ici d'un échec
moi je sais ça fait plaisir ça sent pas
le bon courage et 7
parce que là ça menace ça et ça où il
fait quoi magnus
ça s'appelle une pièce sabah qui n'en a
ni la food & sync ou encore ouais mais
bon c'est à détroit et c'est fini moi
j'ai sept ressemble à du pauvre
technique magnus est ce parce que rage
et cette ça a vraiment la tête d'un
mauvais coup en bas là il a défendu un
simplement sur fou dessine comme peugeot
indemme ses trois tours 7
ouais papa tour 17 non mesdames c3
automatique
et puis on prend et tous à temps il ya
deux tours 1 est-ce qu'on s'enflamme
répond un peu trop vite
ok mais fou des cinq au pire dame cern
ou pire dams et bravo kevin montblanc
dont ben lamb a qui arrivent on met les
barbelés
il faut peut-être tu nous envoies un peu
après m
pour les mettre on n'envoie pas encore
mais maintenant faut qu'on envoie mes
tours ces huit tours ces huit ça serait
beau dommage qu'on n'ait pas joué
attaquant j'en envoie le tourin je suis
en retard je suis en retard je suis en
retard baki ouais mais c'est bon il y en
a plein qui ont envoyé ça va les amis je
les ai mis à monthois chaleureusement et
mais c'est complexe
je le batte chez complexe assez
difficile je pense que les gens de serre
pris complètement fou quoi gonfler sport
l'avoir à mettre des barbelés tout le
temps quoi et tu sais depuis que son
parti on n'a pas grand chose d'autre à
faire ouais my nostra qui domine de
manière stérile un balai c'est très
important de ben tu vois ça c'est un peu
comme le match contre artemiev allant
vers le match de magnus contre artemiev
alors oui à quoi que le début de match
était vraiment chanceux quand même côté
pas chanceux s'est pas mis là il a
beaucoup de réussite au début quand nous
disons sur les trois quatre dernières
parties règlent clairement pris
l'ascendant sur sur maxime mais
absolument stériles comme tu dis mais ce
que tu penses que maxime est quand
j'allais dire peut même la jeu pour
gagner si réfléchit trop en tout cas
maxime qui se réinstallent alors est-ce
qu'il ya du power of tactics quelque
part non de façon il peut pas avoir d'
attaque la dame couvre je crois que tu
as dit le coup ces dames c'est un coup
il n'y a pas d'autres coûts et maxime
qui s'étire maxime tranquille il a vu la
dame c1 c'est sûr et il doit il doit
regarder ses autres options web à la
hisser un essai qui chaque coup et voilà
chaque coup tellement important dans
cette position il prend son temps il
peut pas envoyer les coûts à tempo comme
comme d'habitude à brême 2 dames c3 donc
ces prises prises et thouaré qui est
très tôt h sur la première il faut c4
les années satie joue pour gagner deux
joues pour gagner c'est risqué quand
même c'est risqué mais joue pour gagner
il va faire toi hh 4 ici il va falloir
faire une sortie d'un prime sic
un prochain il faut ici c'est juste donc
tour à quatre lits des dames 17 c'était
tourcoing f-7124 et donc tour à groix
cadre de la dame qui est pour les livres
de l'auteur probable 7 et sur b3 il ya
vous prend b3 et bêtement c'est pour les
coûts auxquels j'ai pensé les trois
aussi un thème des 7 s'était pas optimal
maxime alors que le cr de super blitz
permettait de garder ce points d'avance
d'amd 6 peut-être fait le h4 h4 super
league cesc tourbez qu'attache 5 ha oui
mais la précision prend b2 henri vii et
chacun qui défendra et qui attaque la
dame 600 n'y a pas à j-6 damas trois
tours h quatre dames
ah non merde non pardon pardon j'ai rien
dit j'ai déjà gagné
voilà on n'y comprend rien désolé pour
les commentaires mais c'est tellement
c'est un autre il n'ya pas tour 8 la
sent que le mans tours eux deux à tours
vite il y avait tout reprendre et deux
hoquets tourdot tour des quatre gerbes
sans que ça tombe très mal pour maxime
là non je pense pas non visuellement ça
va je paye c'est foutu mal autant il n'y
a pas de touristes roya tourache 4g
inventions qu'il craque ou moins bien
mais pas grave
comme cette fois où d'un mode 3d c'est
la g5 y avait peut-être tourache quatre
tours h4 ça c'était le coup que j'avais
vu tempo aussi je m'étais dit ça perdure
le pion mais oui là les outils la route
secondes d'attention seconde contre 23
la les barbelés vite vite parce qu'il
est un peu moins bien ouais mais attends
ça peut tout simple ça peut tourner des
deux côtés un je vais te dire ça peut
tourner aussi en faveur de maxime un bon
là ça va être trois g4 c'est bon c'est
sécurisé c'est sécurisé pas complètement
mais ok mais dame prend dames et g4 ou
g4 direct ou au prix j'ai quatre ans
ferme en ferme pas la tour avec j'écris
la toile à +15 elle avait plus de 15 7
tours avec g45 ouais mais bon tu rigoles
et voilà ça joue autant
on va voir pour le bullet c'est bien il
va attendre que ça ouais mais elle est
forcément moyen de faire drôle ronan
mais c'était complètement dévoyé la
loupe et mais ok c'est encore nul mais
avec le temps c'est dur là ouais c'est
pas si facile à jouer pas facile à
laquelle bien jongler avec des fonds
bien ouais
allez un petit échec mais deux échecs
trois échecs avec cat échec pour baby
food et 5 y avait aussi qu'il pouvait
être cool part est tombée si bien joué
il a très très bien défendu je vois pour
le reste c'est pas clair ils jouent bien
ils jouent bien maxime ouais mais bon là
c'est lé pas défendu encore on n'est pas
encore sorti de l'auberge
non mais il a montré quand même des
qualités il a commencé très loin
derrière celle là je veux dire son
acuité souris stick est bonne ouais ben
regarde magnifique ah ouais non ça joue
bien il sera la dernière baca dans une
position là il ya deux fois déjà cette
position de défense allait tourbe et 8
pourquoi on à 8,9 grâce à un tour
pranger de la torah 5
là il nous fait découvrir art parce que
j'aime pas du tout ouais ça fait peur ce
roi mais ça lui j'aime pas ce qu'il a
fait mais bon ok ok magnus mal autant
aussi un roi des deux tours 2 ou roi des
deux tours 2 il a presque gagné
incroyable ouais il va attend et ce qui
peut croire mais gagner autant 3
l'invite brève asie maxime hockey wave
théâtre hockey news joue et on est bien
on est bien pour le bullet kevin on est
bien l'acuité souris singh amis et les
fusées sont envoyés ça fait plus 1 et ça
ça tourne ça tourne la grosse défense un
de max payne est content là il va aller
ravitailler
on envoie les 200 grammes aussi
reviennent c'était le stress 1 c'était
l'énorme stress côté français ouais
super ma super super
fin de fin de segments pour être précis
parce que le match n'est pas fini
pourquoi que les gens partent le match
va durer encore et donc là ça va
accélérer dans dix minutes on a on vient
d'écrire qu'il y avait dix minutes de
pause etienne est donc dans dix minutes
ça va ça va reprendre
je vais être la petite pub chaise comme
comme d'habitude les gars j'ai envie de
dire ce me désole mais mes trois minutes
de pub vont partir un jeu prévient
etienne je préviens le tout cas ils ont
super fort maxime pour rester pour le
soutenir là on lui fait un petit mur je
pense qu'il va venir nous voir si la
lune sans téléphone les fusées je me
suis trompée avec une petite rose
magnifique allée reuss est bien aussi un
relais fusée c'est mérité sur ses cinq
plus un bond après l'hérault c'est aussi
un message d'amour du pakistan ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir donc etienne
résumons on est un tiers du match on
mène d'un point
c'était très mal parti et il a fait deux
victoires chanceuses un peu vain il a
récupéré ce qui est ce qu'il n'a pas eu
la chance qu'il a pas vus sur les deux
premières parties la récupérer après et
là il défend depuis trois quatre parties
il défend magnifiquement maximum et
maxime anus sait plus par où passer quoi
mais ça ça c'est important dans le match
mais pour le moment en tout cas c'est un
énorme si j'ai beaucoup plus vite donc
j'ai bon espoir là pour le prochain
segment là le 3 + 1 ouais c'est là qu'il
faut qu'ils essayent de faire l'écart 1
si vous pouvez tourner à plus de plus
trois ce serait génial il serait favori
pour le bullet à +3 très clairement déjà
la prochaine
ouais vieilles carrosseries qui suit le
match d'ailleurs etienne et caro qui
regardent ou qui ont su leur nom qui
espère jouer magnus demain mais qui voit
maxime sauvage on voyait qu'elle aurait
complètement ont fait suer les
américains à serait une super finale 1
demain maxime qui me donne des sueurs
froides qui laisse paix et qu'ils
espèrent m'a donné sur fois pourquoi il
écrit quoi si tu peux aller très très
heureux mariotti message est content de
du début de match pas du premier segment
battant jeu
du coup tu as envoyé la pub tu envoies
la pub kevin wale a envoyé si tu as
besoin de partir va dire si tu as besoin
de partir de minuit de loisirs jetons
audio je te coupe tant mieux je te
laisse je te laisse partir donc les gars
désole le chat le chat en sueur le chat
en furie du mal a du mal à tout suivre
avec les caméras le bas qui le machin le
tchad c'est pas si simple car ado jours
de plus que le vainqueur du match
d'aujourd'hui de repos est alors
attendez je vais faire une petite manip
pendant la pause moi aussi je suis un
peu avec avec avec baky
donc
hop ça c'est fait je vais rester à jouer
aller retour un peu voir le chat on veut
des pubs on voit les pubs ont été
envoyés si vous voulez des pubs vous
avez les avoir eu un et dix mille record
de la chesnoye je crois que c'est leur
corps je crois que c'est le record là
dix mille pour un match ce n'est pas une
pub c'est pas grave tant pis voilà cette
chasse kohn qui va suer et s'enlacent
qu'une écrit le funambule est y aura
plus de gagnants vue l'être quand blitz
ouais ouais y aura il y aura peut-être
un poil plus de bullet mais bon ça va il
faut il faut qui débute avec un petit
une petite avance coiffure et qui les
deux trois points d'avance pour pour
être favori un point c'est 50 50 de
points je pense maxime est légèrement
devant et du cou et du coup on verra on
verra on verra comment comment comment
ça se passe mais après je pense trois
points il est largement favori deux
points
il est légèrement favori un point c'est
50-50 et à égalité ce avantage magnus
pense ce top 2 40 ghz parano
donc et maxime qui est en train de
réussir son retour ou trois mille cent
cinquante ans au passage petit à petit
alors là c'est sympa c'est sympa ce
match on est un petit peu stressé avec
etienne je pense que ça sent comment se
stresser on qui peut c'est normal bon
moi je stresse un peu de puits a depuis
le début du match je le dis tout de
suite mais bon quand c'est serré c'est
encore plus stressant aussi citer mal
complètement bas du coup tu as plus de
stress parce que le match est terminé
si si tu mènes de beaucoup tu es quand
même moins stressé parce que parce que
tu es bien devant l'as étendue et magnus
qui n'a pas quitté son ordi les devants
il est pas bien manu saint aubin c'est
surtout dans quelques parties qui va
être très mal
ouais non dans sa sent qu'il n'est pas
sûr de lui maxime qui est devant maxime
qui fait mal
maxime qui est grand et bon il va
falloir tenir à maintenant il faut pas
faut pas chanter avant avant d'avoir
gagné le match - etienne il est encore
long ce match décrit tu es petit tu
écris tes petits messages
il ya un beau message du patron qui
écrit ma demande est là quand même
j'ai pas tranché michael demander s'il
n'y avait pas eu trop de bas qui est ce
on le chat après les d'autres attendent
peut-être un petit k qui du coup ouais
je me dis je les dénonce étaient des cas
qui est ouest et u mérite un petit passe
pas là il me dit il passe pas entre les
entre les segments parce que trop
fatigant mais on va rester
j'envoie des petits gars qui n'a dû
regarder quand même vite fait quoi un
petit mur un petit truc mais j'en vois
du kaki quand même si jamais on l'envoie
du cac qui va oui c'est le moment de
ravitailler et a complètement raison pas
complètement raison maintenant je pense
important que tu es là on en profite du
kaki je pense que c'est important
d'envoyer
du kaki ouais j'en vois j'en vois quoi
l'on va de la fusée aussi quand même
mais c'est vrai que magnus n'a pas bougé
quoi ça c'est impressionnant
des gens qui je me rappelle de bacrot
jeune étienne est encore johan les amis
c'est sérieux c'est comme la dernière
fois c'était quoi des fois c'est
maintenant que ta carrière maintenant au
fond de ta carrière ou quoi c'était quoi
déjà
maintenant que tu peux plus rien espérer
ou un truc comme ça ouais tu t'étais
fait descendre quoi le choix paraissant
pas pour les pour les gens un peu plus
âgé je rappelle de macross jeunes assez
terrible c'est un aveu du coup je mets
un peu de patrick bruel du baht macro du
patrick bruel quoi battre beaucaire
faith mais c'est vrai que j'étais là il
ya très longtemps en fait quand je
compte les années d'enfer mais voilà
quelqu'un qui dit qu'il se rappelle t il
dit le mec demander comment encaisser la
baisse de niveau avec l'âge
en septembre j'ai joué du 12 parties
avec une perf à plus de 2000 seth
grahame tu te présentes on va quand même
voilà non c'est pas niveau champion du
monde c'est pas niveau maximum mais
c'est quand même pas rien quand même pas
si mal c'est quand même pas mal mais on
est quand même bien non après c'est vrai
ce qui est terrible c'est que on
contrôle plus du tout les moments où on
va bien jouer où on va mal joué en fait
c'est maxime il peut encore contrôlés tu
vois quand ils se préparent hyper bien
quand il fait tout bien
c'est le sport tout où les prépas les
machins ok tu peux arriver à ton
meilleur niveau mais après voilà moi je
peux plus même si je fais tout le mieux
possible pour un certain moment ça peut
ça peut dérailler à tout moment quoi et
ça déraille ou par non mais des fois je
peux et hyper bien joué deux fois moins
bien joué mais sans que ça soit tu vois
la fin sans que ce soit les conséquences
de
préparation de celles liées à l'âge
comme bon comme les autres sports on est
plus je suis presque
ok je suis à 37 tu es plus est ce que tu
penses y aura les mêmes problèmes avec
le stream
jean charest - bon streamer g 36 37 38
quand arrive comme ça un âge avancé il
est temps de stream
tu penses à un âge aussi avancé je
serais assez bien aux dépens des mets ta
pensée grecque
non mais c'est quoi pourquoi kasparov
arrêté à quel âge il a arrêté un peu
plus de 40
pourquoi cram ni qu'il arrêtait à 45
c'est juste qu'ils contrôlent plus en
fait tu en a qui continuent comme vichy
et comme un an mais qui voit là et toi
on verra kevin dans cinq six ans ouais
ouais mais je m'inquiète déjà je prépare
la reconversion
je prépare déjà la reconversion mais oui
c'était génial parce que je te poser la
question en très sérieusement en fait
j'étais en full troll c'était
exceptionnel
ta apprécié d'apprécier ouais mais c'est
pas c'est une question intéressante
c'est une question d'hygiène de vie
c'est vrai aussi que c'est une question
d'hygiène de vie à la presse de
capacités maintenant on s'éclate et
voilà comme axe est à l'ofce style mais
arrêtez avec vos d'histoire basta le
stress oxydant kevin en ehpad
attends moi j'ai envie de faire sauter
un petit coup d'halfaya avec la halle et
pendant la pause la tétée chose j'en
vois un petit alpha check point fr
sauvage histoire de voile et ça j'ai
envoyé un petit al cheikh sow valises en
sueur allez c'est reparti etienne j'ai
juste eu le temps de faire suer alpha
échec à la magnifique c'est gris
chouquet super que les shoots maxime et
maintenant on sait qu'il a appelé à la
pause magnus il a dû appeler vlad sous
la tour odéon à mais sinon lapin faible
sinon vlad lui redemander pour
non mais justement je veux dire vladan
sur quoi ne joue surtout pas ça s'il
fait quand même
donc ouais ne jouait pas le 3h catelin
ça c'est vraiment des coûts pour le top
top top niveau on joue pas des coups sur
le côté comme ça et c'est vraiment très
spécifique à l'ouverture de maxime donc
h4 ça empêche une bonne phase avec des 5
et maxime joue dans un style est
indienne mais voilà les blancs jouent un
coup h4 sur le bord qui est un peu qu'il
va falloir réussir à justifier quoi il
est donc maxime a quand même pris un peu
trop de temps là au début m'accepter
surpris proximus maxime qui nous a quand
même fermé les positions qu'ils aiment
bien et ils m'ont juste maxime qui nous
a fait un petit signe un il a un petit
peu bu avec son ac b ap nous a fait un
petit un petit coucou à huy by ap ap ap
n'as tu as et on se fait des petits
signes entre nous il nous rassure attend
là il me rassure pas trop là sur son
début de partie
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qui se passe
au caire 5 avec les proches de prendre
ce fou pour pousser fou prend pions
prend tout reprend et peut-être fou g4
après pour gagner un tempo de développer
kg singer ça voilà il me fait peur sur
ce début de partie la hâte en faut
prendre les cinq lacs et prend des 5
oui je veux mais avec l'idée fou prend
cavaliers reprend et surtout prend g5 et
prend des cinq car il est pris pour
apprendre angers 5
ouais mais c'est peut-être très bien
joué ça a l'air pas mal
et après si magnus joue un coup comme
fou 3 ou acheter acheter ça me paraît
être le coup thématiques non pour
empêcher n'en faut 3 3 et h6 des noirs
t'es pas content tu es content mais
pourquoi pourquoi t'es suis content mon
général tu joues pour fc habsheim quand
même ok en fait je comprends rien cette
partie moi je peux pas jouer pour fou
j'ai je peux pas jouer pour ça ou g4
france et 5 non ouais et ya fait la
surfent au prince est sain pour la jeter
dit je t'ai dit qu'il y avait un trou là
un truc qui allait passer ce voyez c'est
pas des coûts maximas cas depuis le
début de la en commençant par fois c'est
atteint 16 fou qui va plutôt angers7
ok il peut il peut quand même la joue et
c'est là c'est pas contre la même pas un
petit grain un petit coup d'échec
ouais il faudrait remplacer le cavalier
f6 le remède vers 17 donc un petit petit
rock ou 1,8 qui a aidé cette f5
je vois un petit plomb comme cela
n'allait pas et là il a un peu de
réussite la maxime pascal aurait pu être
une foutue en fait c'est pas si claires
et que même joué ces six baies 5
maintenant si tu te souviens et une
partie à 4 il empêche que ces six baies
5 mais du coup cela j'ai peut-être un
cavalier à 85 ou un g mais bientôt jouer
8 parce que j'ai l'impression que tu
touches la en plus avec temps fou ok ça
sert à lui dit lève 5 cavaliers ou huit
top 5 c'est plus naturel en fait ouais
j'étais parce qu'il contrôle très très
bien cette case aux saints rois et
quitte à revenir plus tard avec le fou
en 8 pour atari atar de cheval qui peut
aller en d6 aussi bientôt ok ouais c'est
magnifique il a cage de mieux
il est très content là il est très
content maxime il jugé c'est qu'il est
passé très très près de la
correctionnelle
ça va je fais je fais un instant
objectivité etienne magnus donc on l'a
souligné un qui a eu beaucoup de
réussite là c'est maxime qui a
énormément de réussite d'être dans la
partie juste petit moment la korité bas
prix il est peut-être encore un peu
moins bien mais bon aujourd'hui trois
plus ça va oui mais ça aurait pu être
juste l'abandon au thc 5 et des six
semaines acheter les principes monastère
français 4 et f5 au prochain où la bac
et c'est un élève s'imposer à carhaix
mais oui mais oui ma fusée mais là ça a
l'air d'être sympa tâche ajoie pour
maxime
voilà c'est plus que des compensations
ouais non là c'est plus que de la
compense tour a jugé que le noir ce ce
cavalier juste devant le pion des cinq
tours à droite au niveau 5
joli coup avant de faire droit à deux si
jamais tu voulais de faire
cavalier e 2 pour blinder les cavaliers
qui plein de 4 ouais ok bon aux pires
fois au pire f quattro ses nus non tu
passe comment ouais mais maxime je pense
qu'ils jouent pour le gain oui oui non
clairement mais magnifique
ils jouent pour quoi ils jouent pour
qu'il y ait des quatre ici il joue pour
gagner teva lieu 3 qui avait plongé de
aussi oued alger cette dame et g7 way
pour taper un peu sur b2 tour sept tours
qui peut qui peut se présenter c'est
surtout que les blancs ils ont pas
vraiment de coup là je vois c'est dur à
des coups durs à jouer pour le moment il
n'y a pas trop de plans pour quoi tu
joues h4 relate vlad qui va dire la même
chose pourquoi jouer ce coup contre
maxime je joue le contre n'importe qui
mais pas contre lui c'était arrivé là
c'est vraiment incroyable quoique maxime
fasse une boulette énorme et que tout
d'un coup ça tourne comme ça c'est
qu'elle ait des quatre plaqués des cas
je suis pas hyper fan merengue n'ont eu
aucun problème pour les noirs mais juste
en blitz j'aurais peut-être préféré
qu'ils gagnent plus de pièces tour eiffe
car il va taper sur f peut-être tour f4f
fuite ou ou sur le tour cette touriste
aurait fait un retour très naturel
regardez le pion - des noirs il est ici
ce pion le vois pas du tout où le front
g4 qui va bientôt tomber même douteuse
et fuite
et si on mangeait 400g 42.5 commencé
protéger donc dans ma fille tu prépares
fou pranger 4 il se passe quoi là
surtout projet 4 jeu ratant le cavalier
protège américaine protège pardon bien
vu etienne merci damev six fours quatre
fous proche de 4 magnoni prend tout
reprend dame prend dame prend cavaliers
prend pour preuve 4 to this is it aurait
fui trois tours et fuites sur puis on
prend du coup on rajoute une pression
ici bat en effet nagé la finale alors
nettement mieux pour les noirs attention
elle peut être très très importante
c'est important là que ce soit il ya
peut-être 5
non ça va
donc il va mettre la tour en b3 alors à
temps est-ce qu'on peut passer
voilà on va passer facile à les rois et
fluide bien jouer des six puis on prend
pour un v6 aïe c'est pas de bol des
salades attends attends attends il va
montrer droit attends tu peux pas amené
le roi jusqu'ici c'était à deux doigts
d'être gagnons c'est pas de bol
donc il a eu beaucoup de chance dans le
début donc c'est mais attends attends à
tan tan tan tan tan tan il encore mieux
et là encore attentats pas un tour point
f5 aussi un jour avec du jour est ce que
j'allais dire ouais bah ça répète ça
doit répéter
ok ok bon ça va mais est ce qu'elle est
vraiment très très proche il ya eu de la
chance d'avoir ce des 6es tour trembler
6 1 parce qu'il était est à deux doigts
mais bon sur la partie on va dire que on
en a tellement eu bon alors du coup ça
renvoie une sicilienne à y rentrer dans
la flèche nikov cette fois il a pas fait
le fou b5
alors est ce qui va à il vous lâchez la
cavalière 5
ce qu'on appelle la pélican c'est ça je
ne sais pas je n'ai joué il n'y a pas
très longtemps
bah je pensais que les jo 2018 je
pensais que tu connaissais pas moi c'est
pas son ouverture principal à maxime mes
cavaliers 5 c'est un petit coussin pas
vrai pour le blitz était plutôt une
bonne idée
par là il va mettre la dame ou par
contre tu es surpris que magnus et jouer
si vite hélas dû comprendre que c'est ce
qu'il a prévu que maxime pouvait jouer
ça en blitz je sais pas mais là je crois
que cette dame j'ai trop la noms des
intéressés dame des neiges d'amd c'est
la panade là elle serait catastrophique
pour les noirs c'est à partir de 6 il
n'y a pas d'âme des quatre ici ouais
c'est ce que j'ai à dire dam des quatre
tours des vieilles dames à 4 menace que
ces quatre c'est la très dur à jouer
pour les normands
ouais super alors est-ce que d'après ce
que m'a mise
peut-être encore théorique mais est-ce
que ça sud est ce que ça peut suivre ta
partie encore c'est ça ma question je
sais plus et est tombé devant passer à
kevin moi je me prépare je me rappelle
pas mon nom mais je sais on sait jamais
on ne sait jamais c'était contre qui tu
as dit contre eux mais le camion mais
combien beau arménien j'ai pas si on
espère que tu as gagné cette partie
excuse moi te le dire il a tiré
s'annulera en irak
nous sommes très heureux de nulle part
miracle mais d'un mac est ok a tancé en
fait là c'est hyper important s'il
arrive à tous sortir maxime c'est en
fait c'est la question à vous ces quatre
ces forains parce que tu as un peu tout
mal placé pour les noirs oui bon il peut
ya des trucs de marloux à cannes pour
les noirs mais pour le blitz c'est pas
facile
pas facile à jouer ouais mais ce qui
peut faire pousser 5 pouces et qu'adam
cinq dames français 6 3 et fuite
donc je peux risquer de donner un pion
comme ça il le fera pas en tout cas je
sais je sais mais je risque que ces
genres dits des cailloux avaient existé
oui oui oui dont elle a d'ailleurs il y
aurait foot améliorer peut-être fou 17
sur wii regarde pousser quatre dames
cinq dames c6 ou 17 est attaquant g5
vaut prendre 6 ok ouais faut prendre ça
veut dire que ça peut être encore
théorique peut-être etienne pélican
connaît pas mesdames c6 ou 17 way adams
et si soudée cette fois f6 faut prendre
deux peut-être avec l'idée de remettre
un échec-avant f2 d'un mètre 4 ou là
c'est compliqué et très complexe est
parti je crois que peut-être un fou g4
las la bienvenue aux parents fous h 4 x
4 avec l'idée de défendre l'option et
préparez-vous g3 flashcode petit robe
rouge et 3 ça pourrait être théorie
qu'un d'ailleurs ce truc là ouais je
pense que c'est théoriquement vous
puisque tous les coups sont hyper
logique et ça a l'air de tenir pour les
noirs donc c'est que ça doit être
terrible
et ouais c'est pas de bol que ce soit
pas complètement gagné en correction ça
serait pas théorique quoi il y aurait
pas gérer ses pouces et 5 d'amérique
il l'a trouvée parce qu'ils connaissent
cette chance ou là ok c'était la
possibilité après que donc les parois
point f d'obscurs rue d'ham f4 et rentre
là ok c'est peut-être au moment où est
bien calculé maxime il est en forme il
est en forme
alors à sans attente en faisant un bilan
et akwaya pion de plus pour maxime
mais il ya père de fou pour manu ses
activités puisque le roi f1 on a du mal
à à connecter mais bon droit et puis ces
jeux vous que j'avais proposée c'est
hyper logique
ouais ça va se finir en droit au sein ça
va se finir en dro moi je trouve que ça
peut encore jouer des deux côtés 1
je pense que c'est je voyais plus un
d'entre eux sans qu'ils aient cavaliers
d1 là je pense que maxime il veut
vraiment les jouets ses positions
complexes je pense qu'ils se il sent pas
moins fort même voir un peu plus fort
que magnus moan et moi ça me fait un peu
peur quand même sans échanger les dames
alors fou prend pions prendra me prend
est ce que ça peu non ça c'est ça va
mais je pense ne pas être mon but pour
les blancs disons je pense qu'il va
falloir envoyer du h4 peut-être ou et
six rencontres en rien leur parti c'est
trop trop fort beaucoup trop fort d'un
match et je pouvais changer de mains
vides à mach 6 1 parce que si vous êtes
madame jacinthe le pied ouais donc
cavalier d1
du coup il n'a pas échangé les dames
dans les meilleures conditions mais
changer les dames dans de meilleures
conditions
ouais parce que là il est apte maxime
veut taper sur f5 mais bon là c'est
plutôt c'est plus est égale sa douche
pense moi je préfère les noirs mais
après non c'est pas mieux non
après c'est plus fort que moi donc je
fais plus confiance à ton avis combien
porte sur la vérité maintenant ouais ça
peut être non ça a l'air d'être égal
juste acrobatique
oui pour les deux pour les deux oui moi
surtout pour maxime quand même quand tu
commences à faire des twem et j'ai
l'impression que c'est justement que
c'est très bien joué que ça devient
acrobatique pour magnus maintenant parce
qu'il va vouloir toi un tour à 4,3 satin
fin août ou non mais là par exemple sur
h5 tu es obligé de jouer tour g36 ils
font des coups ces spectacles sur h5 tu
avais des cavaliers aux six échecs au
cimetière de la tourelle d'un séjour à
d'anciens attention il est comme un pur
projet 5 menace touraine but serait
atteint
je dis ça je dis rien tombé si bas c'est
le pion à web et c'est fini je pense
fini fini a fini comme en tout cas
qu'ils évitent fous ces quatre
magnifiques jeux super sakho et g4
maintenant menace tourache cinq tours
prince est imparable
ouais aux minima ami a minima a minima
fais nous un petit faut aussi savoir f6
maintenant au moins fou on n'en parle
plus à beaucoup balafon et tour des
quatre comprends je suis cette tournée
guttman ma'afu pranger ici si peu fou
aux quatre donc fo pranger 6e game quand
même ouais mais tour h5 et tour des
quatre et tout reproche cette tourelle
échange non ya pas ou tragiques dont g5
et yappa tour g6 marlou ted ballou ted
ben il joue plus vite bah c'est une
fusée c'est une fille c'est simplement
une fusée je pense que rien à faire ce
qu'ils veulent mais j'ai de commenter on
peut juste regarder et le roda 3150 qui
commence à se présenter aux problèmes de
connexion côté maxime attention ça peut
être ça peut être
il a trois
ok serre mondiales a annoncé remonte à
casser remonte à 4 non non je l'aurais
vu j'aurais vu etienne je suis je suis
en marlou de la connexion je ne me
laisserai pas avoir par une connexion
qui défaillante ça tu me connais je suis
une fusée pour le voir il ya personne
sur pias comme qui voit plus vite
comment une déconnexion je vis pour
s'intituler mois il fit le pion il
rejoint une position qui lui convient
j'ai l'impression qui fait complètement
déjouer magnus un ouais bah déjà un
magnus qui bouge pas de sa chaise à la
pause c'est pas habituel c'est pas
habituel on est bien d'accord
là il est pas bien maxime keys qui donne
un pion comme ça dans le désert
attention de pas de pas se prendre le ja
page six la voilà c'est bien messi qui
pioche et menaçait des cavaliers des 5
tours 8 h trois des cinq peut-être
maintenant qui marche chez pas ouais on
donne des coups bas juge visuellement la
d5 tu as envie y faire un tour et 8 f 3
des 5 c'est sans calcul et non bah ouais
allamano aller le petit dessine co sa
part géré les deux prises et grand
nombre peut-être tourbe est lui le grand
retour bébé tu donnes tout les matchs 6
attendait un bien joué par contre tout
autour non mais oui mais tombé huit
camps et oui bien sûr tomber 8
non mais je mets foucault un set
peut-être même c'est cet ail veut
toucher là il veut défendre la dame c7
c'est pas dans le thème normalement mais
est ok broyeur suis alors quand même
très très bien pour les attend j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas été super
précis ici
la précision n'a pas été de mise côté b
ap j'allais faire tourner vite non ouais
je pense pas je sais pas on n'a pas
alors dit on sait pas mais la dame ans
et c'est juste mal placé way d'alger
visuellement il fallait surtout après
ils s'envoient des telles parties que tu
as forcément une petite baisse de régime
sur certains coups a du coup on voit
cette enquête on est d'accord c'est pas
mal et ça pour le blitz peut-être mais
je en est d'accord que les blancs
doivent être mieux ici par les blancs
sont mieux mais c'est un super coup pour
rester dans la partie
on est d'accord ouais c'est un beau coup
passer un beau coup c'est par l'asa pas
l'air tu vois c'est pas qu'ils aient
trouvé un coup devant la championne la
référence ici je vous avez vu cette
pression je visais f4 mais bon t'as kg 4
4 kg 4 c'est pas de faire du soudan les
doivent à craindre au 24 mai prise prise
même sous prend d'amd cette dame 17 ya
prise des fossés 6 probablement pris 0,5
ok vas-y gagne la manier son casier il
commence à faire des coups quincaillier
des cinq gars mais c'est bien jouer le
général et des six s'il est obligé de
jouer avec des coups comme calais b 5
c'est quand même pas si claire gamme c6
qu'elle ait des six tours des huit noms
ouais ça fait sens
j'ai un peu inquiet etienne dans ce
party game
yakari est pas prêt à se dire ce que pas
perdant tout de suite c'est pas par des
rituels
il doit la gagner quoi fouet à foix
fitia dame bessette là faut trouver ma
foi si c'est nice ou cali des cinq tempo
ça j'aime bien quand tu comment quand il
commence à faire ça c'est bon signe
ben c'était bien très bien joué de la
part de magnus quand même cette partie
où la dame à saint qui fait très très
mal
ouais raté par maxine 8 96 heures à la
salle en ton nom ton 17 km cesag
caillaissé 5 km et jouer toujours eux
jouent le oui non mais je veux bien sûr
inquiet ces cinq mètres carrés ie3 un
truc de marloux
et tout reprend 17 francs f1 tu vois ce
g5 même fou prend f1 d'abord je vais
prendre ce qu'est ouais ok tant
matérielles jouer avec moi jouer un coup
gagnant importe quoi c'est quoi ces
qualités pion de moi c'est beaucoup mais
mais bon on peut récupérer une calloc'h
en f1 et oui beaucoup de trucs en l'air
chez les blancs aussi il faut qu'ils
trouvent
voilà s'il trouve pas bien tout de suite
ça va pas être facile peut-être un tour
c'est un intermédiaire pour ces hommes m
dames si ce nom là il doit aller
chercher dans le foot the problem
inquiet c'est ça que j'ai passé trop
c'est complexe et la cavaille prend 1,3
taux reprend 17 d'un point 17 à d'un
prince is ok mais fou déclare des cats
c'est ce que j'allais dire il ya un truc
qui va venir en d4 quai ceineray je n'ai
pas c'est dommage qu'ils épargnent
danzer d'amd 4 donc il va faire quoi il
va mettre leur en h1 je sais pas mais on
peut bien sûr que la partie n'est pas
finie fait la cam un gros avantage
matériel mais bon il faut le terminer
ça ressemble ça ressemble beaucoup à la
position de sa partie abidjan en 2019
il va faire f 5 n'ont aucun relief 5 je
pensais qu'ils voulaient faire f5 et
essayer de toucher
il a raté qu'à l'étranger 3 ayad à mach
4 ou des matières d'un projet toutefois
d'un projet trois dames 2 on croise les
doigts damage deux dames 8 7
on croise les doigts là est-ce-qu'il
lamalou ted ou pas complètement
normalement ça doit fonds qui doit y
avoir un gars encore pour les 4 à ouidah
match 4 de damages qui doit jouer trois
ou deux
ou d'amd de très bien jouer c'est un
gros coup de défense mais est-ce que
c'est pas fini tout quand même bon il
prend tous là d'un projet de roi des
trois oui c'est ça bédard damas charroi
des deux dames j'ai droit d'être war est
double menace est d'échanger les dames
et de prendre mais tu peux échanger les
dames prendre b2 tu as un pion pour la
qualité quand même bah oui il peut
l'affirmer il ya vous avec deux
magnifiques ou en la pression mais ça
arrive je vais je l'avais ça mais pion
par mois
mais oui non non c'est bien ok ou pas
tout gagner un
il n'y a pas d'âme c4 peut pas revenir
défendre
ok c'était quand même très très bien
défendu de la part de maxime impression
dame ces sept là wells a activé may hamm
et magnus qui a qui a joué parfaitement
à l'eba qui on lâche on lâche pas à baky
mais on y retourne jours à 50 50 pour
cent c'est ça ouais là 50%
quand ça il a plus un pourquoi 50% women
qui est boxing bas il mené 2 points là
il ya un point ils menaient de 12 points
il menait deux points à domicile compte
c'est ok il retourne dans l'est sur les
pas de la première fois de bkc avait eu
à il et il a changé magnus faut aussi
mais là c'est pas très grave que j'ai
trouvé l'homme c'est juste pour signaler
mon chéri tienne ouais mais ouais on
avait discuté de cet échange de foot
case blanche
oui tu avais dit que c'était pas mal
parce que les blancs c'est leur mauvais
fou ouais c'est pas c'est pas grave
d'échangés soutenant c'est pas l'heure
c'est un bon fou pour eux aussi mais
c'est pas grave l'important c'est bien
fatigué tu gardes
le bon choix entre guillemets et puis ça
affaiblit un peu la case f5 alors il va
essayer de la renforcer parfois fuite g6
avec les noirs là je sais pas je pense
qu'un petit tibet quattro ou fou et 3
j'aime bien phu et trois autres à qui ma
souffrance et cinq épreuves cinq bons
deux choix soit x 3 soit b4 fou prend à
deux tours prend 1,2 à vallecas il sait
quoi tu fais quoi sert pologne où tu le
mets où ce cavalier après b4 et ben je
pense que tu peux pas le mettre en a
quatre à cause du bon hockey il a fait
chou navet c4 est l'homme qui donne des
dos ou ou h3 d'abord ouais voilà la
colonne a quand même dame des deux tours
à sa tour et mieux passant à 2 quand il
a joué dam des deux c'est bien ketura
huit tours à laon prendre un gros contre
olemps de la colonne ça ça fait plaisir
peut même faire un fou à 700 jours par
un peu un x 7 à la carte off mais voilà
colin tranquillement quoi ya pas de vrai
il n'ya même pas besoin de de carpeaux
visé le truc
julien cette partie de cartes peuvent
d'ailleurs car pas fini car jolie partie
oui touré farenc qui va tomber au
prochain donc là il a un petit avantage
grâce à cette colonne et grâce au fou
est un petit peu en développement parce
que pour finir son développement m'amuse
doit jouer encore fuité g6 c'est fou
j'ai c'est alors qu'avec les blancs
maxime il est pas mal d'amis ici s'y
prépare tour à 8
il conteste directement et en appellera
le temps de damas cinq à cause de dames
celle là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya du
cavalier g5 ici chez pas pourquoi j'aime
bien
p3 métrage c'est un genre de coup je
comprends pas à fond il veut jouer des
tours à 8 c 4 d'accord ok et protégé
latéralement et il a fait ce qu'il a
toujours la colonne parce que vous
baissez baissé
ouais je pense qu'il n'a pas fait il a
pas été optimale maxime c'est changer ça
va égaliser là non ouais il est pas
mieux il est plus mieux j'avais réussi
ce n'est même son cavalier g3 qui est un
peu la tête ce que deux qualifiés 3
ouais c'est même lui qui doit faire un
petit peu attention la tension maximale
faux peuvent pas tourner dans le bien
jouer qui avaient lieu deux ouais non
non il replace les pièces c'est quand
même lui qui défend un petit peu ouais
après ça a l'air d'aller non quand même
ouais mais bon ok quand en faux quand on
est un petit peu mieux et qu'on passe
directement dans un truc comme ça qu'il
faut faire
il ya un moment d'ajustement qui peut
être complexe mais il faut pas faire un
dame bandama 2 juste pour voir là un
petit dôme belluno un way pourrait faire
un chantage à l'échangé dire ok jusque
là il ya la menace d'un bébé 4 quand
même d'ailleurs il aurait peut-être dû
essayer de me décote magnus la mécanique
est à quai des singles en l'air mais bon
il peut te faire un fou là un petit adam
b4g du hockey damas huit devant une
foule des deux je pense soit juste j'en
ai joué moi d'albé un an maxime bien
comment ça va mal tourner la whey c'est
magnus qui domina bizarrement ce début
de trois plus un flash proche du
bizarrement il a fait quelques coups
bizarre maxime sur celle là c'est
peut-être son petit passage à vide comme
il avait eu contre les bonnes
je te rapelle y en avait eu un aussi où
la foudre et 8 ça fait mal ça mais
pourquoi il va pas jouer d'ambea au lieu
de deux ou trois coups là la dame bien
il y aurait prise est fou à 5
un look noir qui fait un travail de sape
on n'est pas bien on n'est pas bien qu à
bf3 qu'avait lieu donnant essayer de
jeunes des quatre à temps à y perdre le
pion à detroit
qu'est ce qu'il perd vraiment en d3 ok
bon il va jouer sur le contre je h6 et
il va essayer de passer par derrière
ok ça peut tenir par un miracle je vois
pas trop comment ça peut tenir là bas
qu'est ce tu joues avec les noirs ci
soit et si je fais dam des huit dames 17
d'abus géant dames d'amd 8 1-8 pardon ce
que j'avais 1,4 dame prend f7 que je
pense qu'il va faire dans ma vie d'homme
36 même ok c'est un gros poids en moins
dans les deux cas j'espérais que devrait
prendre le truc paris vii naître le pian
h50 h3 mais après c'est pas terrible non
plus les menaces perpète
ouais ça tombe mal la n'y a qu'à lire 6
et 5 encore turques at-on atteint 9,5
c'est vrai à mesdames f cfa à faire
gaffe des rois je suis tjrs avanies g8
quand même le cadre avant qu est ce qu
ont espoir je vois sinon c'était
vraiment mon espoir
tu pourras peut-être faire un cécité
milliers de cavaliers logements ont joué
encore kouassi talent cavaillon j'hérite
ya un petit espoir un petit espoir
oui ce talk et un gîte rural car il ya
cinq ans n'e des villes où les dépêchons
moutons chevaux fatigue et non un k n ya
pas qu il y prend 1,5 à la dame des cinq
malheureusement et là y apprendrez
j'avais demandé il ya quoi
sk 4 way we attends attends attends
etienne f ça ou ils empêchent dame j'ai
deux comme ça
ouais c'est le bouillant y tiens ça avec
10 secondes wade à metz troyes ils
essaient bien merci
magnifique cavalier bouche d'ann dead
rising dorbeaux l'aide d'ambulances vite
vite vite
etienne il va faire quoi dame e1 d'amis
s'y était produit mais oui mais oui
etienne mais bien sûr qui va la chercher
mais bien sûr qu'il va lâcher et l'abbé
ap l'abbé ap oldham g6 impressionnant où
elle fait mal ça là on pourra dire
celui-là il fait plaisir aux elle fait
plaisir celle là est tout
g6 spectaculaire ah ouais mais attendez
mais tu sais quand tu te prends des
défenses comme ça là bas je sais oui je
suis au courant et il en joue
il va jouer son tour b victoire à la
leçon qui veulent jouer d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote tu sais quelle précision j'ai
eues dans la partie que j'ai perdu
contre hikaru sur le cap ce nom j'ai
réussi à perdre avec 99 points de
précision quand même c'est terrible
enfin il m'a fait tomber mes joueurs par
la coutume et 99 points de précision
n'était pas gagnant à la fin ratée
c'est quand même assez ou trop de
réactions la magnus
non666 la ilaha illa il a un peu coupé
la tête
wade arrivé un peu tard non
il répète incroyable de répéter sa
séance en prépa ça avait l'air tellement
mauvais pour les blancs mais à mon avis
l'intervention de l'abbé ap dans cette
position va se faire sentir
maxime qui a changé 1 je regarde un
petit coup le tchad a trop la langue
islamiste ihh qui n'a pas vu la dame en
a 6 il a donné à la dame en l'isle adam
f 5 ça faisait aucun sens comme coup il
y avait jugé 4 il a vraiment donné la
dame ans c'est parmi ceux qui m'aiment
et comment il a pu faire un gc saxe
cobourg vous à un craquage fatigue
pression parce que d'un médecin que j'ai
cadré dares inquiets g4 ça peut pas être
un mystique dame e4 et dame prend 1,4
d'un des trois dames prend des trois
failles a pas de mystique et en fait je
comprends pas comment il peut
m'expliquer quand je suis non il n'a pas
mis ce clic
il a juste il a juste donné nous donne
je suis y avait même de 1,3 alors qu'on
est quand même 14000 là sur le live
je fais entier en six records cette fois
kevin récents records je t'avoue je
t'avoue ce un record bas qui parce qu'il
ya un mois tu avais mis que tu étais
très content quand les mines
ouais non la 14000 c'est un petit record
qui je t'avoue que mais là c'est beau
match quand même ok on a maxime contre
manu sont que sinofert une là il est
super bien là un pion en moins mais ba
ki c'est koi plantier qui est faible
c'est le deuxième stream sur twitch il
n'ya pas être quatre quand même c'est
singh ont bien joué prix seraient prises
ok dame s'est vite il faut empêcher f 5
1 je pense mon avis mais fifa 11 a même
si ce bien jouer c'est sûr gf chauffe de
même de magnus c'est pas possible tant
c'est pas elle est pas clair encore mais
bon piont prend 1,4 c'est quoi c'est
assez c'est qu'un brillant jeune couple
elle est chaude couple je pense oui mais
gérard il faut faire gaffe parce que il
suffit de toi faire une erreur un moment
donné tu leur mets dans le match mais si
on prend le cadre d'un projet si ce fou
fou prend ok ça peut être que mieux pour
les noirs ça peut pas être mieux pour
les blondes jeu ça c'est sûr donc quoi
qu'il ya des 6-17 comme ok mais tu auras
pas le temps je re si je mets le pion à
f/5 je vais quoi je pense que tu dois
faire un gecko ah non il va faire des
6-17 il va il va poser ses pions là mais
maximy va jouer qu'est-ce qui peut jouer
comment il peut jouer peut-être au 3o 3
4 ou des cats
howie attend que trois fous détroit du
coup tu fais quoi qu à trois coups des
trois ans car je pense qu'il commence
par tour g8 et maintenant que trois noms
ouais il peut c'est vrai qu'il peut le
faire mais j'aime pas là il fallait
faire trois ou quatre fois une fiction
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il peut le
faire maintenant ravasi pages et 3 c oui
oui oui
en fait il l'a raté mais magnus l'ua a
laissé la chance de refaire et la re 4
fouet magnus en titre là c'est sûr ça a
été non
quelques complexes en est de même hissé
où il joue gérer comme ça c'est pas
possible c'est très mal joué de sa part
la wii ou trois fautes folle tuèrent
choc complet pour ça se voit pas sur son
visage mais c'est clair qu'à l'intérieur
c'est baky koné dessus est bientôt là
ils commencent à évoquer faut le tuer il
faut le tuer par contre bas qui ce genre
de joueur faut pas les laisser revenir
c'est le moment l'arrêt maxime xx alain
voilà c'est un maxime qu'on n'a pas vu
depuis très très longtemps
by mekas culture il a les murs bab il a
aussi des choses que magnus n'a pas un
les kakis des cas qui s'il a pu mettre
des kakis avant le alors attend un bébé
d'auxerre fo prend b2 enfin les cats
ok c'est pas c'est pas fini mais c'est
mieux quand les noirs alors que c'est ça
devait être vraiment pas facile f5 là je
pense oui je sais pas si c'est mieux ou
pas c'est compliqué l'a34 5,3 kg à toi
si c'est mieux aller f5 maxime quand
même quand même quand même bref 5 c'est
quand même logique un avec food et 4 qui
tombe mois il est en train de calculer
fou des quatre tours prend 1,4 tourbe et
de roide et 3 il a vu que ça gagnait pas
ils tapent dans le web 5 auquel fou des
cats et a dû tomber 2 qui arrive tour à
trois roues à aubes six tours à 3 tours
b cette tourbe et trois au kehrweg 6
mais pourquoi magnus pourquoi pourquoi
tu joues c'est le moment d'arrêter par
fait gaffe quand même marié encore le
bullet derrière et tous ces parfaits
backyard je sais mais attend on profite
donc non mais faut profiter mais faut
pas trop non plus tu vois faudra la
dernière fois j'ai un peu trop chanter
mais tu vois on a un peu chantée contre
hikaru et puis et puis finalement jusque
là il va faire sept des huit tours des
huit là ils menacent points 5
ok faut cinq et on prend ces 5 fu
pranger 3
ces chemins de quoi ça bayer il a dopé
et maxime il a loupé des quatre
terribles ça mais ce qui là encore est
ce que est ce que c'est pas lui qui joue
pour tenir maintenant même là c'est lui
qui joue pour tenir maintenant et du g7
vas-y moi moi j'envoie excuse-moi
excuse-moi bas qui j'envoie j'envoie la
période il faut que jamais du bon côté
seulement par rapport à la caméra mais
j'en vois gens voient j'envoie la
perruque j'envoyais ouais mais j'en vois
gens voient ouais mais on en a besoin
baky et il est clairement moins bien la
grèce a tourné un petit peu c'est pour
ça que j'en vois la perruque un à temps
il défend encore ah oui pareil si fou
des 5 et le curieux qui par tour h5 roi
prend ses 6 il a sauvé encore roi des
six à temps mais c'est lui qui a le plus
en plus au quattro il ya tous rêvent 5
attention tour et six tours et si cela
super outre si sexy voilà touré fils et
beaucoup food et 8 ok bon il dure parce
qu'il peut
perdre pour preuve si ce fou prend h6 à
il va pouvoir switcher le roi de ce
côté-là non non il n'a pas le temps de
switch leroy les perdantes
ces perdants sabah qui et comment il va
chercher au katla food et 4 ok ouais
attend est roi où 3 c'est terrible si
ces perdants
ça c'est le grand classique 1 maintenant
c'est drôle à temps c'est vrai tu passes
par what we phocéen want and we are
maintenant et c'était faux et 5,3 x 100
x et nuls phocéen 3,17 s'était pas nul
non cross c'est terrible ce qui s'est
passé dans c'est vrai ce que je te dis
il faut pas chanter trop vite un ok il
va y joue là il joue là bas mot deux
allers les 17
un coup du mat
un coup du match 7-6 art devient chaud
il a remis magnus dans le match un coup
du mat encore on était deux fois au cou
du mat un coup de main et reis pasqua
sur qui les prend ses six c'est quoi le
bon c'est théorique ça je crois oui ça
existe c'est parce que je pensais me
daems et s'est trouvé ça ok j'ai compris
mais bon allez on est encore dedans
etienne ouais ouais ouais on a pris un
petit coup sur la tête quand même un peu
timidement de ce 3 + 1 à vas-y je te dis
ça tout de suite
c'est dommage parce que c'était un
moment où on sentait que on sentait que
maxime était 20 minutes 10h20
ok ouais bon allez on sent
et que maxime il pouvait prendre un net
avantage là et que et que ma nièce était
en train d'être chaud quoi un peu
dommage pas changer le monde pour rama
nathan cecos x 6 il fait n'importe quoi
peut-être juste rock nom tellement
risqué
ça a l'air d'être juste bien pour les
blancs mais tata pas du cavalier f7 baky
qui va menacer là bientôt on n'est pas
de douala rendu cavaliers pro f 7
je descends highway
on n'était pas loin est sur b4 c'est pas
grave il ya du fou ceccato du c4 on
comprenait pas toi fois ci c'est très
bizarre de la part de minus makelele 5
français bafoue ses deux sur f6 pas si
saddam h5 j'imagine ouais ouais non si
ça doit aller parce que tu fais quoi sur
damas cinq patrouilles pas battre coup
sur walfoot accueille six voitures ont
évité à 49 cents
non non non rien ok c'est 5 la partie
est super bizarre même fou au katla ou
fou des trois habitera j'aime bien les
menaces provoque ckt faut 4 mais je
pense que x 4 c'était c'était un faux
quatrième tapis faut 400 anglais un
meilleur est encore là car hockey parce
que là il peut jouer ces quatre fous aux
4b cet ajout petit rock c'est tellement
risqué
c'est peut-être c'est bien joué il jouit
là ils jouent bien en fait magnus c'est
bizarre mais c'est bien le maximum mais
ces déceptions aujourd'hui mais c'est un
bon tour est las avantage mais en france
poussé entre les deux variantes il a
réussi là le temps de jouer b4 avec les
noirs c'est déjà mieux pour les noirs
mais il aura peut-être pas l'air mal
faire normalement façon le pion isolé
sasu toujours au thème pour un jeu vous
tenir ouais voilà c'est jouer au tempo
bas là ok ça va c'est balance
on ne sait pas la mcb 4 mais il s'est
affaibli au cices quand même un mecha
rallier ces quatre peut-être tu peux
faire sur le t4
non mais là ça va pour les blancs mais
c'est pas inquiet mais le temps aussi
important maximy autant magnus s il est
pas bien la manyu cette pression mais
les deux joué une très bonne partie la
haye d'un prendre cinq tours f6 donc là
surtout il faut pas échanger ces fous de
cases blanches il faut trouver un moyen
là je veux trouver un coup je peux pas
faire tours fc un des quatre fous ces
deux équidés four b3 et je joue un peu
la colonne c'est pense que maxime
cherche plus il cherche après faut faire
gaffe à toi t'en faut faire gaffe à ton
épouse trop stupide bas qu'il faut faire
gaffe à tour g6 aussi un tour je suis
silva ferrer 3 ça c'est pas il fait pas
3 il fait poser b3 j'aimais bien b3 b4
tous ces 4 mai la a3 et ce qui peut
jouer est sur b4 il veut faire quoi à
maxime qu'elle menace bk je pense oui
non mais là ici b4 pour magnus b4 fou
prend à 6 tours prend 1,6 puis on prend
b4 puis on prend b4 tout reprend 1,6
d'un point à 6 francs b4 qu'il prendrait
quatre daims bb&t chèque ok d'accord on
va le voir me dis qu'est ce qui va se
passer probablement et s'est équilibrée
tant ils regardent soit quand même de la
part de maxime qu'il avait toujours de
l'arrière là c'est juste équilibre est
fou c'est 5 suivi de b 4 pouces et 5 et
dames baisse en un mois c'est plutôt
mieux pour les blancs d'ailleurs ça peut
pas être mieux pour les noirs d'un v8 il
veut food et 6.5 pour jeu lattaque sur
leurs mérites j'ai loupé super
d'embellie dessous des 6 ok super
regardez comment il replace ce fou qui
était pas ça c'est non fumeurs mais
l'aca bandage blanc il devient net
nettement meilleur que cavaliers des 50
alors à ses avantages blanc mais durera
dur à convertir évidemment à cause de
tourbe et 7 c'est pas de bol mais pas de
borne est temps que cette dame est
depuis toutes ces années cette
suppression et c'est adam bessette bien
joué dames 1 8
pour cette hausse est ok ouais d'enlever
cette bien joué très bons coups de
défense très indécise beaucoup
d'apparitions encore maxime il va pas
laisser la nulle facilement comme ça
ouais bon coup d'attac dame bessat et
maintenant tu peux la reprise tour c'est
un ouais c'est ce que j'ai dit aurait
pris ce tour c'est un tour ses six
taureaux 6 et aura le temps de voler du
h3 ouais on est d'accord et tienne
manuelle cinq minutes regardez bien
c'est la tourelle bien après un bep sept
ans b 2 si on arrive à choper la 7e par
exemple sur tourbe et 7 il va faire tour
1 je pense aux mirages et six tours 6 ok
ouais alors as tu encore ok il veut
faire mais c'est pas mal joué enfin en
défense
ouais mais si fairway fcv h5n1 s'est
finie en fait j'ai 5 il a bien défendu
là il a fait deux trois bons coups f3
bien joué aussi
oui j'ai quatre bien joué les quatre
prises roi g3 g4 un mauvais coup je
pense tu penses je suis dit voulait
peut-être alors j'ai proche du gant
blanc latour s'est vite c'est fini je
pense moi je fais quoi jeter g4 c'était
vraiment il avait très bien joué magnus
mais j'ai 4 c'était vraiment un mauvais
coup à temps il va récupérer les deux
quand même ouais mais touré fuite chemin
tour et fuit 3g et wi fi 3g 5 auquel ont
droit ces jardins en fête pour les noirs
je te cache pas je converse pressé
perdant 3 h quatre cavaliers trois tours
g5 ou regain g7 aussi une glace iihf et
rouages calcul fait quoi cavalia
croirait la voie pas perdante en fait
mais je vois que les blancs sont mieux
mais je vois pas pourquoi c'est si
claire non c'est vraiment enfin avec du
temps c'est vraiment très très clair
même avec 20 secondes je pense que roger
3 2
c'est ok donc et prend des cats ok
présager les grades faire elle le roi
est coupée ouais nan tu avais raison
mais je la voyais je la voyais pas tu
vois c'est je te le dis franchement la
life as we l'apple 1 rouaf 4 kg 3g 3g
cas qui tient encore un peu tour 4 ou h
trois fours et 5 super 5 tours échec
tour aux deux magnifiques away technique
mais vraiment au poil 1la de maxime il
faut encore la gagner mais alors il a
super bien joué
keonys de 4 3 2 j'imagine un fort c'est
super jet tours 3 échecs roi is it au
registre à certains core games mayhem
noës et tous rêvent 3 ct ok tout
respecter ces dames est apte à claouey
c'est games et game boy
c'était chaud mais ça gagne l'abbé ap
c'était chaud quand même un super super
technicité bouillant roy et maxime
maxime qui enchaîne white yen + 2 il
reste combien de temps il reste douze
minutes il reste deux ou trois parties
dans la cadence
allez ce serait bien de tourner à +2 ou
+3 ouais encore l'anti hinault font
encore un petit là pour être tranquille
+3 on est vraiment très favoris +2 on
est favori mais chaud c'est important et
demain en finale le vainqueur de ce
match là rencontrera le streamer
américain hikaru nakamura
donc ce sera chaud dans tous les cas
ribéry que je l'appelle sa streamer on
est d'accord
oui oui gilles américains aussi c'est
magnifique
ok il s'en sort pas trop mal là dans
l'ouverture maxime il va tenir debout et
si magnus shufu des 5 pour être échangé
ce point du coup il aura une mauvaise
structure
et maxime qui veut jouer à gafsa choix
que maxime il a beaucoup de conviction
maintenant dans ce qui fait ouais ouais
il joue de mieux en mieux il était il
est très très très très concentré alors
ça se voit ah oui les îles à 200%
mais magnus qui a pas tant d'émotions
que ça écoute a il est peut-être pas en
grande forme
on sait pas ouais bon c'est pas à les
antilles et sinko là je pense que ça à
partir la f5
ouais parce qu'en plus la menace du
c'est quoi trop après derrière migros
fiq qui avait lié d2 attention là il
n'ya pas c'est quoi trop prise prise 4
qui va lier prend ok il fait un petit
coup d'abord footsie cède 1,17 je serais
fou dessins croquis et manche je mange
moi ce faux dallas a avantage à là c'est
clair avantage mais bon c'est pas ok
c'est pas gagné à ses avantages ou la
couronne n'a qui peut se présenter 3,8
attention car ces quatre peut-être
attention et c4 irradiation alors il
peut souffler sur quel essai quand on a
dû tout racisme on a dû dame prend des
cinq dans le premier cinq parades
d'apprendre et 3 non alors ici faut donc
l'idée car elle est à 3 il va falloir
gérer cette position n'est pas si simple
pas si clair en vrai ouais ok bien jouer
h5 tourbe et vite
ok on joue pas la colonne alors on joue
on joue les leroy hill origins qui on
vous le fait que les blancs n'ont pas
trop de rupture c4 assure pions prend il
veut dame prend qui avait pensé 4 monki
fuite
ok peut-être qu'ils égalisent comme ça
ah oui tiens tout après le thé en c4 est
vraiment fort croyait fort de tourin ya
tourbe et 3 où elle fut au tour à cette
ok ça va être ça va être drôle
ouais ouais ça va être drôle ou f8
pouvoir trouver trois tours b 3 mais la
tour des rondes et un tour d un roi et
farrow devrait faut appuyer trop f1 le
carrier vraiment fort
ok mais c'est pas mieux pour les blancs
je pense et je sais pas tu la joues
moins 4 maxime le qualifiant de vide le
carlito 4 heures est bien vrai jouet
pour avoir un tour des 3 après sur des
oeufs des tours un tour des trois maïs
décisif ça c'est à table et noir du cou
qui sont pas si mal voilà c'est maxime
qui poussent là il a fallu cette sphère
f3 pour les blancs du coup pour empêcher
ouais mais il n'était pas facile d'avoir
ce 4 on l'a vraiment vu au dernier on la
voit nourrit oui mais non commenta on ne
joue pas et tiennent à vous laisser voir
wade 2 c'est quoi ce coup mais ils vont
rester là je pense qu'au fric ce qui
s'écrit sur f2 la tour b 7 et voilà baky
qui se présente alors atteint issue
retour à white 5
l'idée c'est que surtout rien tout
raciste uva l'état pff deux fois par
exemple là tu peux faire web 5 août où
rêve s'est tout de suite ok il fait tout
réussissait tout de suite mais là il roi
des deux jeux préféré commencer par un
autre coup que que tous rêvent cette âme
et roi des deux rois g5 bien joué les
tours f5 l étendu la finale encore un
mais je pensais comme les blés blanc qui
prêtent plus un puisque lequel on
s'éclatait vraiment tellement fort c'est
les noirs qui pressent pense ouais c'est
clair parce que parce que tu as les deux
faiblesses des cinquièmes de et dès
qu'on va en manger ok c'est fini tôt et
sinon on fout il va il va vite arriver
on sûr ouais je suis inquiet je suis
inquiet en fait je suis inquiet tous
rêvent cinq cavaliers aux trois
peut-être vokkero l2 c'était bien joué
mais là ok tour 17 et sirois le 3eme
faire quoi même roy f5
bon c'est pas risquer en fait ouais
c'est balance s'est balancé tu as raison
c'est pas mieux pour les noirs mais je
vois tours à huit qui fait flou g7 qui
est prendre des six tours prend b2
talent fou qui arrivait en d4 aura
toujours à trois tombes et caveaux torah
3b 3 way s'est balancé tu en fais tu vas
le truc c'est que dès que tan dung qui
essayent de gagner il ya des idées de
contre l'austérité
j'ai pas trop aimé le tour beckett de
maxime baca sambou
fait roi des deux harmonies leroy c3
mais la tour b 7 à 3,8
tous rêvent cette fois 6 x 6 x 6 km et
si c'était quoi la à steak arriveront à
prendre les trois points
ouais mais bon que ce pré carré des
hoquets tour à quatre géants pensons que
c'est magnus qui vous l'a gagnée
vraiment qui masque un bien qui a validé
deux cavaliers des deux etienne à 4,5
way to rocha trois dessins qu'il faut et
protégé s'étend aux caisses et des
questions dès maintenant c'est magnus
qui joue qui joue la gagne au ces des
fusées pas qu'ils allaient là on pourra
peut-être invités magnus pour le
prochain au bled streaming et acciona
voilà ça va être un joueur talentueux et
avait pas cavalier des deux là qui est
des deux il y avait du tour b 4 par
contre tours à 6 tours beckham qui va
des profs ou prend tout reprendre tour
des quatre essais bien jouer un petit
peu là ensuite un petit peu ont su un
petit peu pension qui peut jouer
bordelais attend ya pas tour à 4 ici qui
est chiant pour ce faire le pion à
passer mais tour à 4 way non mais là il
est moins bien maxime et là il a tree
hill a mal géré un moment il était bien
son fou hausse est là il aurait dû
lâcher ce truc
il rentre dans cette finale
ok tour des quatre quand même toujours
aussi souhait elles sont où ces chances
là ce cas les escales nuls quand même ou
pas il est difficile en tout cas tu dire
objectivement sans parler de si on la
tient ou pas déjà juste pour en fait
j'en sais rien je pense que ça doit être
perdant quand même mais ok tour f5 l'a
vu sauf way to rape seule chance
pourquoi tu tellement seule chance genre
les blancs ils veulent quoi si je fais
autre chose
ben voilà il a gelé tous absents il faut
forcer trois là sinon tu peux si tu mets
ta tour un froid après pour ac 3 6 4
c'est sûr que ça va pas aller
bref c'est pas parce que tu veux
envahissant jeu pourra taper tout le
temps sur jets d'eau d'accord c'est pour
ça qu'il fait tour quatre en fait pour
colmater le trou fois là et là il va
essayer de mettre là tout ranger 4 mais
bon là tout ranger cat est moins forte
qu'en f3 il va essayer de passer
derrière la maxime
voilà c'est pas clair je pensais que ces
nuits j'aurais sûrement
objectivement il ya de grandes chances
que ce soit nul voilà il tente avec
kafka toqué bien jouer puis on prend
attendre on peut pas jouer même g4 ici
maintenant ok puis on prend tout reprend
voyage à 5 tours garage 5,3 g ton g5
hockey tour f5 tanger ce à quoi il va
sûrement ouais non c'est pas dit qui la
tiennent encore il ya plein d'idées pour
les blancs ouais voilà non mais c'est
hyper compliqué et coûteux et tour g5
non ok attention il a pas tord g5 là il
ya des loupes et il a loupé un tour g5
tout à l'heure c'est la finale de pions
elle était ok c'est terrible ça là ça
doit être perdante entoure
tu vas voir quand même tout retour de
encore il va perdre et non à ces morts
là il a loupé un tour j'ai surtout rejet
caprice prise droit gesma regarde
comment c'est bien joué c'est fini
dommage dommage
ouais ouais elle était très difficile
bien vrai magnus 1 il faut reconnaître
plus de 3000 c'est la dernière partie
etienne ils sont combien il a pu se
hisser ouais il n'a pas réussi à faire
l'écart mais c'est dommage
moi je dirais que sur le sueur sur le
scénario total du match c'est quasiment
le score logique en fait parce qu'il ya
quand même une période magnus de
domination il a pas il n'a pas converti
et là c'est comme celle là elle est
importante
tu connais pas la berlinoise évidemment
non jeu que j'ai jamais joué ça j'aime
et analysés est ce que tu penses c'est
pas étonnant le choix de magnus de
rentrer dans une berlinoise à ce moment
du match une ouverture que maxime
maîtrise si bien moi je crois que là ni
l'un ni l'autre contrôle vraiment ce qui
se passe quoi ça fait déjà combien de
temps 2h45 près de 2
je pense pas qu'ils qu'au début du match
ils avaient envie de jouer la berlinoise
mais il a peut-être pas aimé comment se
sont déroulées les parties d'avant donc
ok il tente qui manque peut-être de
lucidité aussi dans les deux là
maintenant ben là c'est dur si vous
voulez prendre des décisions si vite
[Musique]
après après tant de pression bon c'est
pas facile
ouais c'est complexe bon là il doit s'en
vante un petit peu les doigts parce
qu'ils voient que la maxime la
berlinoise c'est un peu c'est un peu le
spécialiste et glacée quand même une
ouverture que tu peux perdre avec les
blancs je vois c'est vrai comme la
l'espagnol avec détroit où c'est
vraiment très solide
moi tu me diras il a failli la paix ont
aussi avec ses cadences avec la pression
du match et où tout est possible et yen
et donc après après cette partie là les
amis juste pour vous re situer un peu ce
qui va se passer y aura trente minutes 2
1 + 1 essai au terme de ce un plus un
con
donc on désignera le vainqueur du match
donc qui sera qualifié pour la finale
qui se jouera demain à 18 heures il ya
combien de postes entre les sept
je pense qu'il va y avoir encore un
petit 10 minutes 10 minutes donc ouais
surtout loupé paul belette impasse parce
que ça va être dur arrive dans celle là
tout peut se passer
c'est rarement eu un tel maintenant bail
en attribuant naadam sur sur une saison
tu as quatre matches comme ça sur 64
matchs fois donc un maximum est basse et
soit vous savez quatre matches sur 60
temps à dix qui sont qui sont moyens
bien tu en a quatre qui sont géniaux tu
en a cinq qui sont passés le même menu
snack habituel qui est ce que j'ai sur
les 60 matchs tu as tu en as 45 à jeter
et en a 4 vraiment très bien quoi
voilà on est dans celui-là est la
position est très chaude etienne et
genesis il veut aller coller un petit
colis et mme bello h5 non tu la sens pas
comme ça moi je le vois plutôt revenir
en d 3 e cat way il veut forcer un b 6
pour fermer cette tour 1,6 c'est ce que
c'est et je voyais comme ça je m'affaire
carioca tg4 est rien c'est mieux pour
les blancs je suis pas juste très bien
parce que j'ai 4 si tu prends pas gfk
top 5 donc on est obligé de faire fou
prend tout reprend mais là c'est à la
regarde toutes les pièces oui d'erika c4
d'ailleurs ces quatre bien joué il a
éclipsé les g4
il doit y avoir quelque chose ici c'est
5,5
il ya peut-être fou prend 1,4 qui tient
en tout rend fou prend ses cinq sur
tours c4 il faut prendre deux échecs
bref je n'ai pas c'est pas fini là il a
peut-être fait ces quatre c'est un bon
coup et ses 4 ça un triptyque où trouver
un bon coup maxime
et si je fais cavaliers prend un essai 4
il fait ici aussi c'est bien joué
surtout en ce sens il veut carrière
peut-être même tour
il ya tour g4 aussi pions prend tout
rejet 4 ouais c'est sale et des rayons
jouets et sur cinq a cavalé français 5
prises et tour prends ça c'est pas clair
encore un mais oui mais oui ok tu que tu
presses latu presse parce que tu as tu
des français 5 x 3 voies qu'elle prend
cinq points trois films ou tandis que
michael et voilà le plus 2
là il a fait craquer là ça joue vraiment
au physique 1 sont au 6e tour g4 c'était
vraiment très très fort et il faut la
finir quand même aller [ __ ] 6 voilà
ouais j'ai 5h 4h quattro un tour et
fuite près ce prix se fout des cas tu es
fou au 3e manger sain car les âges pas
trop hph quattro et on signe food et 4
un petit peu c'est un petit peu trop
solide se fout des cas tu es fou je sais
ok bon c'est tellement la sécu et
sécurité un ok faut faire gaffe
insécurité sécurité c'est ce qui avait
un peu fait retenir f
ouais et parfois ce qu'il a fait mais
bon ok c'est tellement gagnant que ça va
on souffre encore un petit peu tout
rachat je pense ouais bah il faut wef à
sécurité sécurité dû coûter moins en
sécurité
c'est terrible ouais à trop vouloir
sécuriser
il a très mal joué la très très mal joué
là les derniers coups techniquement
c'est terrible
sécurisé rien du tout quoi non non là
c'est tu sais quoi elle et elle est
vraiment chaude à la c'est bien parce
que cinq tours h4 n'est pas vraiment
chaude mais les rois eux deux vite vite
de l'autre côté vite va me chercher ses
pions encaissés finito là c'est fini
taux tombe à qui que l'acquis des pions
avance ok là il peut jouer roi détroit
le roi il va contrôler tous ces
trois-quatre maintenant et ça laisse
aller là là là c'est fini c'est gamme
voilà ses gammes répétées des deux fous
des deux et offrant à 5 fu d2 et ses
gammes et c'est une reste une non on
aurait de plus la fusée la fusée séguin
c'est shobaki un ouais j'en vois un
petit gars qui a les gens voient gens
voient qu'on va du kaki aussi que je
vais devoir me fonder une petite minute
vas-y je te reste absente et donc les
gars on en est où on en est on en est à
la fin du 3 + 1 donc il va nous rester à
une demi-heure de jeu maxime qui mène de
deux points mais je rappelle que c'est
plutôt normalement joueurs norvégiens
qui est plus fort dans la dernière
cadence il va rester huit parties c'est
ça va être s'arrêtent exceptionnellement
tendu est ce que magnus va réussir à
revenir c'est possible c'est quand même
le champion du monde je rappelle que
maxime numéro quatre mondial contre
magnus carlsen le numéro un mondial ça
va être ça va être ton dax de chez temps
dax ça va se jouer
ça va se jouer à rien les amis ça va se
jouer à rien je vous rappelle j'en
profite
faire les petites [ __ ] pour casque
homme quand même qui organisateurs de
l'événement vous pouvez si vous
souhaitez progresser aux échecs prendre
un abonnement sur la plateforme chaise
comme vous devez avoir le lien parfois
qui tombe dans le chat même si là il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de messages
on pourrait prendre un abonnement vous
pouvez progresser c'est super bien fait
c'est moi pour la peine qui est fait les
leçons en français et vous avez une
quantité
astronomique de leçon du coup sûr tu as
comme avec une semaine gratuite vous
pouvez aussi si vous souhaitez
progresser checker ma chaîne youtube et
ma chaîne twitch pour ma chaîne switch
ya le lien juste en dessous bitstream il
y avait juste en dessous de 2 la chaîne
quelque part vous avez aussi ma chaîne
youtube du coup si vous tapez bitstream
comme c'est écrit juste en dessous de
moi ici comme sur le twitter vous allez
le trouver
la finale ce sera demain donc à 18h15 ou
nakamura qui est déjà qualifié et qui
commentent en ce moment même le match
2 / sur sa chaîne perso donc le streamer
américain que vous connaissez peut-être
ses plus gros streamer des chèques au
monde
s'il ya égalité à la fin du match ça
c'est une bonne question dans le tchat
il y aura quatre parties de départage en
1 + 1 donc ça départagera les les deux
joueurs
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir d'autres
d'important est-ce que j'oublie est-ce
que j'oublie quelque chose je vous lis
d'envoyer une petite pub bien entendu
parce que bon ça fait quand même plaisir
on va envoyer et j'ai le petit drapeau
il faut les chaînes du coup c'est cool
allez on va envoyer on va envoyer une
pub qui fait plaisir et on va voir je
vais vérifier que techniquement tout est
bon qu'on n'envoie pas un message pour
me dire qu'il ya quelque chose à
rajouter je vérifie que ça tourne bien
aussi sur youtube
c'est bon ça marche aussi sur youtube
donc c'est parfait
ce qu'il ya quelque chose une règle un
truc non il n'y a rien à dire il n'y a
rien à dire les amis il n'y a rien de
plus à dire on est tout bon alors on
peut envoyer un sondage
est-ce que je commente en mode binôme
total avec baky où est ce que je tente
un mode un mode football allez on va
envoyer un petit sondage
si ludovic peut envoyer le sondage et du
coup bas qui s'adaptera on fait quand on
fait comment on tente on tente une
adaptation du bas qui fait le mode foot
alors on envoie le sondage on va voir ce
que ça donne avec un bas qui tentera de
s'adapter
je ferai des petites passes d et g serré
d'adapter avec un baky qui sera partout
on va envoyer les petits sondages
donc après néant normalement on aura sur
ma chaîne perso une interview de maxime
surtout s'ils gagnent je pense qu'il
passera une petite minute mais
rapidement parce qu'il a le gros match
demain donc on verra tout cas merci
merci à tous de suivre ce match en notre
compagnie vous fait plaisir les gars on
retrouvera maxi mais aussi à la fin du
mois avec d'autres compétitions ça ce
sera sur ma chaîne perso donc n'hésitez
pas n'hésitez pas à suivre pour avoir dû
maxime de partout et activer la cloche
et pour voir des échecs d'un point de
vue plus global
pendant quinze mille 15 mille quatre
cents spectateurs les mecs on bat des
records pour de vrai quinze mille quatre
cent c'est quand même beaucoup les gars
je vous cache pas je vous cache pas que
ça fait beaucoup de spectateurs je vous
cache pas c'est un petit peu insein
surtout qu'ici 3000 spectateurs sur
youtube on est un peu 18000 on va être
un peu 20000 à un moment donné ça fait
ça fait un peu beaucoup de gens pour
suivre des échecs on m'aurait dit ça il
ya encore deux ans j'aurais pas
forcément cru non mais c'est cool ça
fait plaisir surtout maxime qui nous
sort un gros match mais 20000 ça fait
plaisir c'est beaucoup c'est mérité
méritée avec un maxime comme ça maximy
les mérites les 20000 spectateurs très
heureux maxime ouais il est très heureux
du support qui là on lui peut-être qu'on
lui renvoie on va lui faire un petit mur
d'eurostat est ce que tu sais combien de
spectateurs on a eu le max avec youtube
combiné à temps je lui envoie quelques
roses pour le ou des fusées mais les
fusées il ya trop l'habitude ballet des
roses melero sait jamais hein parce que
les roses c'est vraiment un message
d'amour et c'est ça que j'aime bien
c'est si tu veux mais tu m'aimes l'autre
jour tu vois j'ai joué contre un pleutre
sur 3com et j'ai dit aux gens à envoyer
des roses
j'en avais même pas envoyer les pleutres
on envoyait un message d'amour et c'est
ça que j'aime avec la rose du pakistan
c'est que c'est vraiment un message
d'amour à l'humanité c'est à dire tu
vois c'est quelque part on dit nouba qui
ce temps on vous aime
tu vois ce que je veux dire non mais tu
sens ce message d'amour qui transpire
c'est c'est beau si tu veux ça un vrai
message d'amour
non mais c'est extraordinaire
si tu entends qu nation c'est
extraordinaire avec le petit drapeau
derrière du pakistan les petits et les
petits chevaux et tourner un petit peu
en stress là haut un mur de il demande
un mur de cas qui est ce là et le cas
kia gt sûr tu vois j'ai dit avant le
match c'était important d'envoyer les
2800 sauf pour avoir les cas qui j'ai
senti que c'était important pour ce
match reste concentré maxime quand même
mes oncles effet on t'envoie on veut que
des kaki dans le camp des kakis pour
maxime que des kaki que des kaki il
avoue que l'émoticône est juste
extraordinaire l'émoticône cas qui est
extraordinaire mais c'est peut-être pour
ça c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils le
maximum il est en super forme
aujourd'hui
il était très heureux juste avant le
match ils voient sceptiques acquis et
c'est tout bon il se dit tiens on va
peut-être me faire un mur avec amel est
vraiment oui il est vraiment passé sur
le chat est tous en tout à l'heure il a
mis magnus sont les envoyés des cas
qu'ils font a été content qu enfin c'est
bien bah ça fait plaisir de voir un peu
du cac qui coiffe un je ne sais pas non
mais baky c'est face à fait plaisir les
attentes qu'on reste un petit peu
concentré il faut qu'on reste concentrés
et maxime je vais te concentrer beaucoup
je vais je vais essayer je vais essayer
on va essayer de faire la même chose que
contre fait d'os la dernière fois
j'essaye de faire un peu le foufou aux
commentaires et je te fais des passes
des savoirs on essaye de faire on avait
bien réussi avec fait d'os on s'était
super bien des ménages qui m'a justement
justement cité en stress tu te laisse
guider et un tuba ideatic pendant 2-3
par qui
tutu non mais tu te laisse guider et
puis tu fais du bas qui quoi tu es là tu
je te connais quoi tu fais des petites
reprise de volée et était parfait quoi
ça dépend des parties 1
je vais préparer des petites fusées des
petits barbelés des petits trucs en tout
cas c'est un super match baky c'est un
grand plaisir de le commenter avec toi
je préfère le dire avant la fin parce
qu'on sait pas comment ça va s'arrêter
ça va se finir je sais pas quelle tête
on fera dans 30 minutes bas qui ont peut
être on peut être bas qu'il offre ou
baky ou baky w un lacet
on peut ne pas être bien on peut ne pas
être bien a baissé soit là parce que non
mais il fait un super match il va
continuer a super bien joué
toutefois on verra ce qui se passe tout
fan c'est arrivé étienne ya deux choix
c'est soit l'offre soit ewc bac i love
you back iew il n'ya pas d'autre
alternative
il n'y a pas de baky giga peut-être un
double bac iew en fait à part contrebas
qui est ce si à des partages pas qui s
il ya des partages as tu vas pas être
bien non mais il a plus de la halle et
plus devant n'espère il joue vite quand
même il est très bon la souris nous a
montré dans des défenses des trucs
magnus le seuil de choc un peu regardez
là pas de réaction il a été se mettre un
peu d'eau sur le visage ça se voit mais
il n'a pas vraiment de réaction
il est sonnée quoi tant mieux écoute qui
restent sonnés après les unes unes c'est
ok ça joue vraiment ça joue beaucoup sur
la chance donc il faut que ça tourne
bien là une ou deux parties c'est fini
tôt cet ornement look et on va souffrir
pendant 20 minutes
j'aurai plus de chance j'aurais même dit
c'est une vague c'est une vague le une
cfa luis et cicta un peu de réussite tu
prends la vague en fait ouais tu es tu
là comme il ya plus de maxime ok ça peut
être une
abbassi maxime prend la vague la vague
la mène
la mène jusqu'à jusqu'à carqueiranne là
il prend la vague de biarritz j'arrive à
41 ça il pleut à carqueiranne l'un c'est
l'enfer ça fait pas plaisir et art et
loisirs la connexion un peu en sueur non
non ça va ça se passe bien la seule bad
news c'est que quand il pleut à karkh et
hype le lendemain chez moi c'est ça
c'est ça c'est pas la bonne nouvelle
quoi quand tu dis placard kewin allait
bien c'est parti ces partis baky magnus
qui allaient blanc il renvoie le 4 et
maxime qui envoie la sicilienne des six
sa part pour un fou les cinq etienne pas
de pas de nash d'offres et cavaliers 17
choix offensif de la part de maxime qui
joue pas les variantes avec fu 17 pour
échanger à 6h le fou cavalière 6 il
vient attaquer il va jouer du g6 nom du
feu au cices fawcett etienne pour le
moment partie théorique et équilibrée
encore ben magnus jeu ou ma variante en
fait c'est ce que je joue avec les
blancs et que maxime jeu souvent aussi
est ce que est ce que c'est une variante
qui est qui donne un avantage aux blancs
ou s'est étendu non s'étendent plus
étendu ses voix c'est du blitz face aux
et d'une une donc de toutes façons c'est
tendu donc on se sent que matic la
voudrait jouer pour la case d3 la magnus
qui qui joue décati fait la prise en
passant mag maxime qui a quand même les
deux pions centraux mais mais mais un
pion des six qui a du mal à avancer et
tiennent pour le moment et donc il a
part au caire plus qui peut devenir le
monde et encore et avec peu de temps
c'est un peu embêtant et le pion par
action hors éléments coûts maximaux je
me souviens plus où aller dame b 8 par
match joué il ya peut-être des cavaliers
ces cinq cavaliers prend 1,4 qui peuvent
traîner un cavalier à trois ils
augmentent la pression des quatre îles
ils échangent le pion puis on prend dame
prend il y aura foule des deux qui
chassera encore la dame est et magnus à
y aura encore le pion b2 mais magnus qui
assez toutes ces pièces sorties et
maxime lui et à qui manque encore de
coûts de développement mais s'il fait
fouet cette rock etienne ce sera bon
côté côté français c'est ça en fait la
c1
dynamic man c'est pas clair parce que
soit il finit son développement et il
peut être mieux
soit il peut il peut perdre tout de
suite alors à signaler quand même parce
qu'on a inventé les qualités du joueur
norvégien avec peu de temps sur la
pendule maxime cadre de la bande points
4 là c'est spectaculaire c3d vite j'ai
aucune idée de ce qui se passe a l'air
complètement gagnant pour le joueur
français non roi prend ses 7 et au pire
on échange 4 et on a un magnifique
il a fait là le fou 3,4 tempo ouais foot
et deux dans la recette d'un bep cette
maxime x 5 et chacun qui peut encore
arriver etienne à la loupe et le fou des
deux peut-être
ouais mais attends ça a l'air d'aller
parce que pour lui il ya quand même une
pièce de plus côté français magnus va
bien devoir la reprendre cette pièce
vous prend quatre cavaliers pros qui est
important ouais dame programme times
ok ok ok ok ok allez allez allez le
joueur français qui a un pion de plus
c'est une partie très importante et yann
impasse à +3 ça pourrait décider g5 un
coût qui est toujours dangereux avec ce
puriste qui est difficile à défendre
qu'à valence incapable de f4 home est
fou c'est trois des quatre clics et
maxime des quatre villes des quatre
jouer oui
attention il ya encore du cavalier e
4kings revenir à 6 h six cavaliers 4
encore mais bon il a [ __ ] on comprend
ce cavalier
ok c'est bon le canadien on sait si cela
tour en 18 voilà c'est bien ça ça arrive
la tour ambiguïté le pion b2 qui va être
chaud il ya pas de tour à trois échecs
il l'objet d'échangés les tours c'est en
train de se dessiner côté français mais
attention blocus sur casse blanche
etienne quand même côté norvégien
je ne sais pas s'il peut la gagner mais
voici ça ressemble à 3 des 6 3 des 6 3
des 5 sens c'est en train de au fouet si
g5 à temps il va faire b4 nom de l'autre
côté j'ai des sages sont pas pu ranger 4
à ya peut-être eu 5 puis on prend
cavaliers prend cavalière trois
cavaliers prendre l'un il pourra pas
prendre messieurs loin qui soutient au
moins 5 allait prendre un bain de foule
au 44 soit a fini à temps ça a l'air
d'être finie la attend il défend encore
il défend encore jours encore attentions
auxquelles défense de bonus qui défend
en avançant le pion qui va falloir
arrêter côté côté français et le fond ou
trois qui est magnifique côté magnus
éléphants c3
quelle défense du joueur norvégien
etienne ouais c'est terrible ce qu'il
est en train de faire attention faut pas
la perdre un faux prend h6 qui peut
tomber
il va la paire maxime calis et cet échec
ouf les cavaliers à 6 ouais enfin il
n'est pas sorti du bois il va perdre
tous les pions c'est terrible ce qui
s'est passé le roi c6 ok c'est
incroyable etienne qui a laissé cinq
bien joué qu'elle prend bessette a
peut-être h55 ils appâtent n'y a pas le
temps je crois pas il a pas eu de bol un
neil a pas eu de bol de pas la gagner
celle-là mais au petit matin ce qui va
et ce qui va s'en sortir du bois il a
encore beaucoup plus de temps que magnus
1 c'est important ça ouais le roi qui
arrive en f3 cavaliers au cap à l'est
puis on prend un shampooing pour la paix
nulle ok ok c'est pas si mal pas si mal
à laisser bien ils gardent qui garde ses
deux points d'avancé et c'est pour ça
que c'était sûr important etienne de
creuser le trou parce qu'on sent un
magnus très résistant un plus à un call
défense il nous a sorti le champion du
monde
ouais mais maxime aussi parce qu'il est
passé par peut-être une position presque
perdante même temps celle là alors là la
patte la base des concentrés en une
heure il a peut-être eu 3 seconde de
déconcentration et c'était déjà trop la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il réussit dans
l'ouverture en tout cas à mettre
quelques secondes de pression à magnus
et on sait que 8 9 10 secondes peuvent
faire la différence dans cette cadence
et maxime qui repart avec une structure
c3 détroit comme il y en a plusieurs une
fois eu dans dans le match et magnus qui
semble bien dans dans l'ouverture dans
ac et noir bien sans moi mais ça vaille
alphonse et 8 quand même là kebede deux
cavaliers aux quatre bombes n'ont que 5
offre un petit coup de 1,4 alors les
coûts de 1 à 4 à 5 en bullet c'est pas
mal parce que tu prends de l'espagne
cette dame c'est 2 et ce pion h7 là bah
ouais tu joues tu vois un cavalier g5
jaillir ouais on va voir on va déjà
prisé des quatre réaliser des cas ça
fait plaisir le fossé 6 1 pourquoi je
peux dès que tu ne t'y as préambule être
c'est tellement compliqué etienne tu le
sais aussi bien que moi voilà à ça à
sortir les coups et ce qui peut essayer
de jouer la colonne à nant lappion
détroit qui peut devenir fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est les noirs qui
vont
ans à avoir un petit avantage se
dessiner mais bon maxime et encore des
quatre sous le sous le coude
c'est pas assez loin d'être aussi qu'il
peut arriver bon là c'est fou des 6 4
qui répètent fouet 4 propose les changes
des fous sur fonds propres katia dame
prime 4 on n'arrivera pas à doubler les
pions là il va prendre les pcistes tati
prend et cavaliers ou 5
ça doit être son idée attention quand
même un haut-fond bessette qui a rallié
g4 il se passe pas sûr qu'il ait procès
6 damage de roi et fin d'un machin roi
eu deux salles ont joué cette pièce
maxime c'est pas juste une pièce maxime
petit calcul web on joue et on l'a dit
la dame sait de qui défend elle est
important à ce cavalier qui va se
retrouver en a 7 mais bon il pourra
rebondir il ya dieu 5 qui va tomber non
il part par là et toura chaos joli coup
de la part de maxime tour à 4 magnus qui
prend tour f4 la tour qui rejaillit et
il défend le pion à f2 cas l'élégance un
de la part du joueur français etienne
ramener cette tour a pour défendre le
pire est que c'est impressionnant
bah c'est compliqué là je ne sais pas si
c'est bon ou pas mais les touristes cinq
tours et story 3 écoutez pas si c'est
vraiment pour f ketura cattori requête
tremblait mais il nous régale je pense
je pense que c'est très bien joué et
yann honnêtement ça ça m'a l'air d'être
du très très haut niveau en bulles est
là cette partie kf5 le pion qui tombent
tous rêvent six cavaliers h4 ça fait
tellement peur etienne ja ja passe ça
passe au diable y mettre un n'y a pas du
tout aya fou prend ce match donc il ya
quel geste his way mais attentons
français de fou prend un tour f3 wac se
passe autour des 2 tous rêvent de tours
2 alors cette finale elle donne quoi
comment l'évaluer à une pièce de plus
pour un maxi mais il ya des pions passé
royal fou qui va venir en d1 ça a l'air
de bien se passer etienne mais c'est
complètement gagnant il faut le gagner
encore ouais tour de il menace des 4
maxime où il va gagner le prochain coup
des quatre qui tombe il doit éviter avec
des 5
il doit hésiter avec des cinq mais oui
voix il faut prendre le pion mettre le
pion aux six le fou qui va revenir vers
g6 à vii mais voilà
ouais ouais ben cette attention quand
même hein y'a encore des pions passé
côté magnus
il faut pas crier victoire trop tôt tout
rage de bien jouer pour jauger de wall
auront alors à temps quatre tours j'ai
83 ses gammes
sega et magnus manuscrits magnus qui
s'effondre c'est bon donc et plus fin ok
allez olla l'austin risque c'est la déco
c'est la déco etienne etienne etienne on
va pas les fusées et les barbelés pour
la cour etienne rappelle toi
rappelle-toi du match contre hikaru
attention etienne s'est tendu à ses
calmes orchidées c'est quand même le
champion du monde en face maxime qui a
trois points d'avance qui réalise un
match majuscule mais bon il va falloir
le porter jusqu'au bout ce match et
notre maxime qui en grande forme et qui
envoie les va faire acheter sur et du
petit rouage cette info aux cavaliers
hausse est ok au sein que c'était un
très bon coup je pense de la part de man
is ok geste sans accroc de tout d'eau
attention quand même là le royal st
cloud plongée 5 pts est ok il a joué du
coup un fou ces six là où cavalia 2 5
pour couvrir à simone pouces et 6 c'est
quoi ce que réal pions g6 en l'air il ya
tout en l'air la la il nous a fait un
coup c'est quoi ce que j'allais prendre
trois mois s'ils voyaient là ils jouent
tous tempo là il me fait un peu peur
mais bon peut-être que ça tours j'ai
trouvé à manger 5 encore c'est
rocambolesque mais ça peut passer la
tour qui va venir en aide 8 ça peut
aller mais attention des cavaliers ou 4
etienne qui il a un peu de réussite et
maximin c'est un miracle là c'est un
miracle qu'ils soient encore dans la
game cela il pourrait être rails pour
être foutu déjà mais ça ça peut faire
tilter magnus un ouais faut pas que ce
soit là aussi la tient à la cave a lieu
4 6 1 il ya peut-être ça me prend je
relate basson s'ils gagnent celle là
c'est fini mais il peut la gagner en
plus un c'est incroyable il faut que ça
tourne du bon côté à ryadh mg6
heureusement il n'y a pas joué
ok toit fluide la bon alors ouhlala
jaser de gamme ça ça va être comme ça
tout ça menace c4 ouaya s'est passé kck
3d de encore ça pouvait bien des très
très proche de signer des projets d'un
g5 d'alger est simple le joueur français
qui va qui va revenir on va voir c'est
50-50 maintenant non il est pas moins
bien
tous rêvent de il est pas moins autour
rêve de bien jouer et non non il est pas
moins bien il est pas moins bien mais on
était très proche de complètement
gagnant on pourrait faire venir jouer
aussi tourcoing f1 cavaliers pranger 3
il va faire quoi 5à il va envoyer le
pion h au ces territoires
il veut jouer tout à 6 il a écrit
franchement incroyable ce coup h5
incroyable ça fallait le voir au la
pression qui met avec ce courage si cela
est vrai mais attend il ya la dame qui
revient qu'il ya le carré des cinq afu
prendrait 5 qui défiant ya placé trois
filles on prend quelqu'un c'est chaud
bref j'aime ça croit ses pions remplacés
4 est ce que c'est que peut-être qu'ils
gagnent wade 3 qui a et b des 2/3 des
deux fous prendre trois oui il faut
prendre trois naturels ouf ça y va il
peut pas faire d'abord un cavalier c'est
kalou avait trop abandon abandon +4
etienne on va au bout la voilà la wii là
on y va on y va on envoie les fusées on
envoie les roses on en voit tous les cas
qui va je suis pas bien il lui fait
tellement mal et lui fait tellement mal
étienne parent était donc très dure
rarement maxime faut tenir
magnusson choc total entre choc total à
les manuscrits en train de s'écrouler
ce serait sa première défaite en speech
est ici au total elle est importante
elle est trop importante là il est pas
bien manyu cela sur la photo sur la
caméra il est mal
il est mal aller il va vous aurez aussi
il va falloir assurer tête renvoyée du
fou j'estime qu'au ballon lorsqu'il fait
tour ans il vient tous les ans un si on
gagne élus latins pour maxime quand même
beaucoup de réussite à la réussite à un
peu du côté où pourrait se voir beaucoup
de réussite ce soir y ait un peu de
réussite mais c'est tant mieux c'est
tant mieux on va pas s'en plaindre faut
trois là n'ont rien de temps là kevin
hill
17 minutes c'est pour ça que ce n'est
pas encore fini il reste un gars
beaucoup c'est parti on est sur la bonne
vague
on est sur la vague ok tu sens le
cavalier 5 qui va arriver à bientôt
bien sûr la blinde et malheureusement
mais peut-être affaire karachi
maintenant est-ce que tu son cavalier de
5 arriver quelque part là bientôt mais
peut-être maintenant même si on prend
dame prend d'alger 5 kg 6 pions prend
faut qu'ils jouent faut qu'ils jouent là
le joueur français etienne bah ouais ou
là
sous ces 4es je pense qu'il a calculé un
truc et il a complètement changé de
direction
ça arrive n'était pas un problème de
connexion alors ça va non non c'était
pas un problème de connexion aux caisses
et 5 c'est quoi ce coup ce sont ces cinq
des cinq voies et cesser ces étranges
etienne mais ça ressemble maintenant
unis john d'espagnol des foulées saint
cloud qui est en train de très bien se
classer le cavalier qui vend ses 4 way
les casques maison bretonne pages web
cattin c'est pas un an qui coûte
développement c'est ian buruma colonel
et ya pas de f 5 1 pour le moment une
carence et croître la caisse de 5 ok f4
et ça va partir alors attention et à la
case aux 5 pour les enfants ou pour
jouer les pilotes mais ok c'est mieux
pour le blanc a clairement d'aller 15
selon maxime rey après après en bullet
ça c'est vouloir de position j'ai envie
de te dire c'est quasi du 50 50 en fait
ouais y avait pas un tour propre
stratégie
anon l'adam et eve ont été protégés bref
cette cavalière 5 qu'ils pouvaient mais
ça marchait pas ou peu importe
ok il défend tout il défend tout je sais
pas qui est mieux et honnêtement je ne
sais pas qui est mieux ouais c'est très
tendu s'est peut-être égarée enfin
régalé entre guillemets sur cavaliers
partent en f3 laquelle lieu deux cas les
géants qui avec trois années maxime prêt
pour aller toucher les 15,3 et le
cavalier noir qui n'arrive pas à toucher
la case au sein qu'il n'y avait pas à
donc c'est vrai que c'est mieux bien
joué il ya tant b2b de l'albédo l a pas
fait il va mettre le carignan f3 etienne
est ce qu'on va envoyer un dame b de
cavaliers jacques hérail h2 pour kg 4
saihi commencé à mettre la pression mais
bon ça ça a pas l'air d'être
spécialement mieux quand même 1 dames 5
il va non il ya des ailes à n'importe
quoi le cavalier qui placent sur des 6 7
voilà c'est magnus pendant qu'il me
cavalière 3 bien joué et ce qui va
pouvoir celui du bien et ça va les
attendre car dès ce soir contre six
ouvrages de f 4g trois super ouais c'est
très tendu puis on prend ta appuyons
prendre on apprend ça va échanger fou de
foot j'ai quatre noms qui ok il a fait
ça fouette fin fois je crois peut-être
la corsa échanges et y a pas infligé 4 à
la fin et c'est juste égal trouver 7 et
y'a rien alors il peut faire ça l'info
qu'ils apprennent maximale faire les
marlous liffréen longtemps ah oui oui
non là il faut faire le marlou en tout
les marlous du circuit le fond il faut
jouer un peu la pendule
si le peut mais il va pas y arriver
c'est vrai qu'ils n'avaient pas beaucoup
possible de faire ça bon après c'était
pas facile de gagner beaucoup de temps
en fait quoi que roy 3 tu pouvais gagner
15 20 secondes au minimum quoi allez
c'est pas grave mais stable s'il
continue de bien jouer c'est pas vrai
nous on met la tête sous l'eau pour on
n'est pas là pour faire les marlous il
ya eu quatre parties en plus cinq ans il
y en a eu cinq parce que c'est la
première et la deuxième russe à paris
juste pas connu deux parties mais en
tout cas il doit rester cinq deux
parties 5 maximum 6 donc sévère qu'il a
cassé quasiment des balles de match la
tiennent pour pour maxime la moindre
victoire nous amène au bout c'est quoi
cette ouverture ça se répète nage dans
si c'est un âge d'or qui est parti
es tu là reconnaît etienne ce soir la
nage dorff à les cayes clients aux 5
maxime qui est le meilleur joueur de
nash doivent peut-être de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs son ouverture fétiches sont
il vient de jouer un mauvais coup là
cavalier cs5 c'était un peu bizarre j'ai
l'impression
ouais ça a provoqué beaucoup de héguy
l'indre au centre mais le roi allèles
dame de magnus avec tous les fous les
chevaux les trucs là il est aussi sous
pression
5 très bien joué il toucha et touche le
futur échec pour la fuite qui le défend
mais il va perdre une de ses pièces
maîtresses offensives et défensives
maxime il est pas que c'était pas
complètement foutue heureusement pour
lui alors attention est prête même fou
prend ici c'est un tueur fou prend ya
tout reproche 6 etienne qui a l'air de
faire très très mal
ouais ça fait mal peut-être faut prendre
ou un cahier ici ok j'ai si c'est pas
mal allez ça va il défend encore pour le
moment et le roi qui repart à rebrousse
poil
allez va faire pions prends je pense et
jouait la colonne ben ouais c'est pas
clair l'appui aux français que tu sais
absolument pas clair alors après
attention les cavaliers sont quand même
menaçant des cavaliers prostate qui
peuvent tomber bon pour le mans il ya le
pion b2 sous pression mais la position
pareille extrêmement dangereuse impasse
que ce cavalier qui prend 1,7 peut faire
mal un etienne ça peut aller le truc
c'est que manu tu cherches un gain
direct et il perd du temps s'il ne
trouve pas il va être mal autant le
joueur norvégien il envoie cavaliers
prend 1,7
l'idée de les ranimer moi je suis très
mé on prend bd le roi c'est un tour b un
faux prend b2 encore mieux il a fait ces
trois jours à chaud que de magnus la
haye a peut-être dû cavaler prend 1,7 la
manua 3 maxime il a loupé non mais
attends y a pas d'échelle est pas clair
elle est pas clair elle est pas clair
c'est quoi le matériel c'est égalité
matérielle
ouais c'est mieux pour magnus j'ai peur
il a loupé il a loupé un fou à 3 nuls 1
y avait refoulé 2 qui faisait nul
ah oui là il a raté une répète mais bon
il va pas forcément la perdre 1 elle est
très chaude d'un rêve de henin
la même des deux tours des deux dames 1
avec l'idée sur fion preuve cinq dames
berne a joué par ben ali a l'air ok dam
des deux peut-être cavaliers detroit
tomber deux tours prend oui jouer ou
encore il prend du cavalier il va perdre
ses quatre cavaliers il va récupérer les
g2 bon il est pas bien il est pas bien
mais peut-être il pas là il va la tenir
de justesse sur le fil cavalière qui a
très bien joué la crise prises roi des 4
je crois qu'il est il et il a un tout
petit peu en retard et tiennent
malheureusement mal est là là là faut
qu'ils me la joue jusqu'au matt etienne
je veux pas voir maxime abandonnés ici
il faut que je porte qui les perdants
ben je sais pas mais gère dans tous les
cas s'il perd la partie je veux pas voir
maxime abandonné avant de voir un [ __ ]
de matières l'échiquier bakiev maxim
tour à cannes
mais oui as tu penses qui la tient la
wah wah wah là tu attends tu attends 3,8
f6 du vélo tu vas faire tout recettes et
à cette date ou longtemps pour longtemps
il faut la jouer le plus longtemps
possible maxime pourquoi il le fait pas
pourquoi il le fait pas mais si elle
vaut lui apprendre à le faire
il est trop gentil trop gentil bien
qu'il soit trop gentil ouais mais les
autres s'ils lui ferait il lui ferait
amanissi lui façon % c'est le seul qui
le fait pas c'est le seul qui le fait
pas et yen il y avait lui permet de
rester concentré pour ces parties là où
il ya plus 3 quand même aller il manque
il manque toujours une victoire pour
aller voir facile magnus qui joue le
répertoire facile ouais il a sorti à la
sortie de répertoire à sarsat sa quasi
transposerait position qui est
complètement égalisant tu allais il faut
il faut aller la chercher à les mac ni
maxime qui a une victoire sont des
balles de match à chaque fois etienne et
là il a une position tout à fait
correcte avec les blancs damas quatre il
est même plutôt un peu mieux nos
relations ces six pions à 7 la dame qui
est bien placé les prochains coups sont
très importants
tombé 5 1 des coups assez élégant de la
part du joueur norvégien
bon assez bizarre aussi élégant et
bizarre la fois ils s'organisent
allez peut-être dame h4 partir de
l'autre côté ouais allez peut-être dû à
cuatro asymco way aller sa part la tour
élégante qui a plu énormément de cases
dame de produits gsm ou d'ailleurs ça va
ça va j'allais dire n'importe quoi ou là
j'ai peur quand même là voilà il y en a
partout mais regarde le fou qui est mal
bon allez ça va ça tient pour le moment
à maxime que la scam cac et prend et des
deux fous prend prise
c'est une petite tour en d1 en kit a
évoqué le pion en b2 il y avait eu
devait pas y avoir de tactique pour
gagner derrière position et très
complexe a ouais là tout peut arriver
dans celle là à noter que les noirs
peuvent sortir du cloître facilement
puisque le fou protège la tour je
préfère quand même les noirs un
personnellement mais bon j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt les
manuscrits à l'initiative du jeu ici il
n'ya pas tour d un simplement ici
pourquoi tour il y avait autour des 1
alors peut-être herman tour c'était
catastrophique au foot français si ce
faux procès si ça passe français si tu
penses c4 c4 j'aime bien quand même il
veut il veut c 5 etienne chasser cette
dame là qui est bien placé 15 heures
comme coup ouais mais attention elle
pourra venir on est quatre voiliers il
est dans le très dur là maxime allais
faut la tenir celle là aller au bout du
bout il ya une victoire contre le
champion du monde quand même et yen il
est important ce match il est important
de maxime allais b5 c'est bien il se
créa les îles secret sont contre jeu et
va pouvoir envoyer un pion mois qui va
qui va aller au bout
attention il ya des échanges
c'est une finale avec un pion de moi
même et le contre jeu et puissant il
peut pas mettre une tourelle en un fou
prend ses 4 b 6 puis on prend a6 a7 a8
ouais on est on est on est coupé ce
qu'on est bien
des camions eux mais on devrait on
devrait la tenir il ya énormément de
purin très difficile à jouer en bus
latin c'est très bien joué quand même os
x
allez-vous et 4 j'aime bien c'est bien
joué à les maximes 3,3 bk tomber sauvé
ce fou détroit rockets ouais ok alors à
temps leroy cain est ce qu'il veut pas
lui joué le nom peut-être qui sait il
s'est ravisé d'aller lui vouer le
voulaient en tout cas mais voulait le
mas route et là bas mais il n'a pas pu
un peu comme dans cette fameuse partient
où il a monté le roi contre la dame à
l'esc amiens en plus avec la partie
elles durent etienne celle là il faut
quand même la tenir là c'est vrai mais
géré par là que c'est une partie qui va
qui peut laisser même une nul ici laisse
des traces un côté côté magnus si la
gagne pas on va faire un petit poucet de
foudre de hockey je pensais qu'ils
auraient poussé de tous des quatre mais
bon il récupère les pions là je vois pas
pourquoi il serait perdant maintenant
présent il va peut-être même commencé à
pousser ouais c'est peut-être même lui
qui va jouer pour gagner mais pas quand
même il aurait dû jouer foulée trois là
alors attends il ya quoi il ya trois
pions passé lié côté norvégien
malgré cet échec échec
ouais mon corps le mans il prend son
temps à il veut passer par derrière
attention quand même droit j'ai deux
nombres f3 ou là où ça me fait peur ça
etienne pas peur là si je suis en sur
les pions qui avance côté côté norvégien
qui avancent même titre au t2 il y avait
g 3g 2 c'était match après c'est dur à
voir c'est dur à jouer tellement
d'heures de jeu pour les deux joueurs
ouais c'est terminé
et maxime une nouvelle fois qu'ils
abandonnent directement il reste combien
de temps etienne on est on est quoi on
est raccord à +2 et il reste il reste 5
minutes 03 il reste deux parties
quoiqu'il se passe il en reste deux
allez une nul suffit à gagner le match
et tiennent une nul suffit à gagner le
match et celles à carreaux kahn qui a
été envoyé par par le joueur français il
faut qu ils la tiennent celle-là pas
laisser de place au doute etienne parce
que c'est magnus là qui a pris
l'ascendant sur les dernières parties
c'est lui qui gagne les moments chauds
et il est dans le match et on sait que
c'est un prédateur 1 le joueur norvégien
il va falloir vraiment mettre les
barbelés l'aïe et enfin enfin enfin
gagner ce match officiellement et
enterrer complètement les espoirs d'un
triplé pour pour magnus en speech s est
peut-être un petit coup comme ces cinq
qui peut partir oui il minimise le
centre g que c'était g46 gagné une pièce
cce
c'est catastrophique il est obligé de
sacrifier la pièce cc c'est compliqué là
mais allez c'est pas encore finie
etienne dans cette partie il ya quand
même les pions il va falloir à la
défendre mais va y avoir un lieu à
cannes 15 ans était gamin c'est gagné 7
d'avancé terrible tu as même nul 1
d'ailleurs oui bah oui mais c'est aux
nuls celle d'avant elle était à le match
que ma joue encore un petit peu là quand
le match était gagné etienne il mais bon
allez il nous fait suer allez il faut
plus là j'en peux plus quelque chose il
faut que moi j'en peux plus il faut le
tuer s'il bat mois il reste quoi y reste
il reste trois disent pas il reste une
partie derrière en vrai c'est la foi qui
n'en reste plus qu'une
non mais il en reste qu'une derrière